GET STARTED ON TODAY'S BUDGETS
OF FIVE HEARING I HAVE BEEN
ASKED TO RETURN DIRECTIONS
REGARDING PUBLIC PARTICIPATION.
IN TODAY'S HEARING TO HELP
INSURE THE SAFETY OF EVERYONE
HERE TODAY. WHILE ALLOWING FOR
PUBLIC ACCESS TO THAT SPECIAL.
TODAY IN ROOM FOUR THIRTY SEVEN
WE ARE HAVING TO PHYSICALLY
DISTANT AND PERSON HEARING. AND
WE CAN ONLY ACCOMMODATE A FEW
MEMBERS. A MINIMAL CONDITION A
STAFF AND A LIMITED NUMBER OF
PUBLIC AND MEDIA SO WE CAN KEEP
SIX FEET OF SPACE. THEY'RE ALSO
STRICT PHYSICAL DISCIPLINE
PROTOCOLS FOR THE PUBLIC TO
ENTER AND LEAVE THE CAPITAL.
AND FOR THOSE HERE TODAY TO
MAKE PUBLIC COMMENT AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. I WILL
RESTATE THIS ONE PUBLIC COMMENT
AGAINST BUT IF ANY MEMBER OF
THE PUBLIC AND THE ROOM WISHES
TO SPEAK. THEY WILL RAISE THEIR
HAND THEN I WILL ASK THEM TO A
PUTS A MICROPHONE. WILL ALSO
HAVE PUBLIC COMMENT YET
TELEPHONE. WE WILL HAVE PUBLIC
COMMENT AFTER WE'VE HEARD ALL
ITEMS ON TODAY'S AGENDA I WOULD
ASK THAT THE PUBLIC RESPECT
PHYSICAL DISTANCE SCENE AND NOT
TOUCH THE MICROPHONE. YOU'LL
HAVE ONE MINUTE FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT EACH. YOU CAN EXIT THE
HEARING ROOM ONCE YOUR PUBLIC
COMMENT IS DONE OR READ OR
RETURN TO USC THE PLEASE
OBSERVE PHYSICAL DISMISSING
UPON LEAVING THE CAPITAL.
INCLUDING LIMITING ELEVATOR USE
JUST ONE PERSON AT A TIME.
PANELISTS THE ALLEY- IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ARE
PARIMAL THE TODAY. I ASK THAT
EVERYONE SILENCE ELECTRONIC
DEVICES. AND PLEASE MAKE
YOURSELF WHEN YOU'RE NOT
SPEAKING THERE WILL BE NO VOTE
IN TODAY'S HEARING. TODAY WILL
BE HEARING FROM THE CALIFORNIA
MILITARY DEPARTMENT. THE OFFICE
OF EMERGENCY SERVICES AND THE
BOARD STATE COMMUNITY
CORRECTIONS. IN ADDITION TO
BUDGET PROPOSALS WILL BE
GETTING A BRIEF OR MAYBE FROM
EACH DEPARTMENT REGARDING THEIR
MISSION AND ROLE IN THE STATE
PART OF OUR DISCUSSION TODAY
WILL FOCUS ON THE ROLE THAT-
YES. PLEASE COORDINATING WITH
THE MONK OF IN NINETEEN MIXING
DISTRIBUTION EFFORTS THE MOBILE
SITES TO ADDRESS GAPS IN EQUITY.
FINALLY OUR LAST THAT I WILL BE
AN INFORMATIONAL ADAM ON THE
RECENTLY RELEASED REPORT
TITLED. REVIEW OF STATE
STANDARDS AND INSPECTIONS FOR
LOCAL DETENTION FACILITIES. WE
HOPE THE DISCUSSION WILL BE A
JUMPING OFF POINT OF ON HOW WE
CAN IMPROVE CONDITIONS INSIDE
THE FACILITIES. THAT THEY ARE
SAFE AND CONDUCIVE FOR
REHABILITATION. AND IDENTIFY
THE EVENT IF I GAPS WE NEED TO
FILL FOR PROPER OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY. THANK YOU TO
ALL THE PANELISTS FOR JOINING
OUR HEARING AND I LOOK FORWARD
TO TODAY'S DISCUSSION AFTER
EACH PANEL. A LITTLE I WILL
OPEN IT UP TO THE SUBCOMMITTEE
MEMBERS FOR QUESTIONS OUR FIRST
ISSUE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
WITH VARIOUS BUDGET PROPOSALS.
WHEN YOU DO SPEAK PLEASE STATE
YOUR NAME FOR THE SUBCOMMITTEE
AND LET'S GO AHEAD AND BEGIN.
WE HAVE OUR FIRST PANEL READY.
THIS IS A CURLED AIRBENDER WITH
THE CALIFORNIA MILITARY
DEPARTMENT JEFF IT'S IT BY
TURNING UP. WE HEAR YOU AND WE
FEEL NOW. OKAY GREAT SORRY
ABOUT THAT I AM. I LEFT IT JUST
REALLY QUICKLY- PROVIDE AN
OVERVIEW OF THE- DEPARTMENT WE
ARE A STATE. CABINET LEVEL
AGENCY DEPARTMENT- WERE ALSO A
VERY LARGE MILITARY
ORGANIZATION OF ABOUT EIGHTEEN
THOUSAND- MEMBERS OF THE
CALIFORNIA NATIONAL GUARD BOTH
AIR AND ARMY- WITH THAT WE ARE
PRIMARILY FOR FEDERALLY FUNDED.
I GOT 95% OF OUR FUNDING FROM
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HOWEVER.
CALIFORNIA ALL EIGHTY THOUSAND
MEMBERS MOST OF WHICH ARE ARE
PART TIME MEMBERS I SHOULD I
SHOULD SAY SO THESE ARE
CALIFORNIANS WHO HAVE WHO LIVE
AND WORK ACTIVITIES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA AND THEN- SERVE PART
TIME IN THE CALIFORNIA NATIONAL
GUARD IN THE MILITARY- THE
GOVERNOR IS OUR COMMANDER IN
CHIEF. AND SAID THAT WE DO FALL
UNDER THE COMMAND CONTROL OF
THE GOVERNOR AND THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE AND SPECIFICALLY THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES WHILE WE'RE IN
CALIFORNIA AND THE- GOVERNOR
AND THE OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES. CAN USE THAT ANYTIME
THEY NEED US- OUR MISSION
REALLY IS TO BRING FORTH OF A
OF A ROBUST AND UNIQUE. SUITE
OF MILITARY CAPABILITIES
WHENEVER CALIFORNIA NEEDS US.
THESE CAPABILITIES. I CAN ARE
ARE FEDERALLY PROVIDED. AND
ARE. USED WHEN WE ARE STATIONED
OVERSEAS LET'S SAY A SUPPORTING
EFFORTS- AS PART OF THE ACTIVE
DUTY MILITARY. THE SAME
CAPABILITIES WE CALLED JUUL USE
CAPABILITIES. ARE JUST AS
USEFUL TO CALIFORNIA. DURING
EMERGENCIES HERE AT HOME- SOME
OF THESE CAPABILITIES INCLUDE A
LOGISTICS WE HAVE THOUSANDS OF
TRUCKS A HIGH WATER TRUCKS.%
HUMVEES OF COURSE- AIRCRAFT WE
HAVE CARGO AIRCRAFT WE
BASICALLY ABOUT AIRLINE. WE
HAVE- DOZENS OF HELICOPTERS. A
LARGE AND SMALL. WE ALSO HAVE
ON MAY- OR PINE AIRCRAFT
CAPABLE OF PROVIDING A UNIQUE
CAPABILITIES TO CALIFORNICUS
SUCH AS FIRE MAPPING ETCETERA.
WE HAVE A UNIQUE SEARCH AND
RESCUE CAPABILITY WE CAN DO
THAT- IN ALL KINDS OF-
DANGEROUS CIRCUMSTANCES OUT TO
SEE IT AFTER AN EARTHQUAKE WE
HAVE SPECIAL UNITS THAT ARE
SPECIALLY EQUIPPED AND TRAINED
TO GO IN TO THE RUBBLE ADVISED
PEOPLE- WE HAVE MEDICAL
CAPABILITIES THAT WE'RE USING
RIGHT NOW. DURING THE CALL THAT
CRISIS THAT I WILL DISCUSS IN A
MOMENT. WE HAVE SECURITY
PERSONNEL THAT HELPED LAW
ENFORCEMENT BOTH. FIGHTING
TRAFFIC CONTROL TYPE SECURITY
OR PROVIDING SECURE DIRECT
SECURITY OF THAT CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA AND WE HAVE. DONE
THESE TYPES OF MISSIONS-
RECENTLY. WE ALSO HAVE A
COMMUNICATIONS CAPABILITIES
THAT EXCEED THOSE OF ANY LOCAL
AGENCY- AND SO THAT WE CAN.
ALLOW FIRST RESPONDERS AND
INCIDENT COMMANDERS TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND THE ENVIRONMENT
THROUGH OUR ABILITY TO SECURE
THE HIGHLY SOPHISTICATED
MILITARY COMMUNICATION SYSTEMS
THAT WE CONTROL- WITH THAT SAID
I'M GOING TO MENTION OF JUST
SOME THINGS THAT WE DID IN
TWENTY TWENTY IT WAS A HISTORIC
YEAR I THINK FOR EVERYONE- BUT-
NO. DIFFERENT FOR THE
CALIFORNIA MILITARY DEPARTMENT.
OUR BUSIEST YEAR EVER. I SHOULD
PREFACE THIS BY SAYING FOR THE
CALIFORNIA MILITARY DEPARTMENT
NEVER DEPLOYS A UNILATERALLY WE
ALWAYS WORK FOR CIVILIAN
AGENCY- PLAN WERE DEPLOYED
DOMESTICALLY HI TYPICALLY THAT
MEANS- CALIFORNIA. GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES-
HOWEVER WE MAY BE PASSED BY
HELLO YES TO SUPPORT OTHER
DEPARTMENTS AND WE HAVE THIS
YEAR AND I'LL MENTION THOSE IS
I KIND OF GO THROUGH SOME OF
THE METRICS THAT WE CAPTURED OR
TWENTY TWENTY. SO FIRST IN THE
BEGINNING RIGHT IN THE
BEGINNING OF THE PANDEMIC AND
MARK ARCH WE DEPLORE FADED-
ABOUT TWO HUNDRED FIFTY SERVICE
MEMBERS TO THIRTY FOUR FOOD
BANKS IN TWENTY COUNTRIES AND
REALLY HAVE BEEN THE STREET
FOOD NONSTOP EVER SINCE THIS IS
A FULL TIME MISSION THAT'S
REALLY GOD ALMOST AN ENTIRE
YEAR- THAT IS IN SUPPORT OF THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY AND WE HAVE
DISTRIBUTED A NEARLY A HUNDRED
AND TWENTY MILLION MEALS AS
PART OF THAT EFFORT WORKING
DIRECTLY FOR THE COUNTY FOOD
BANKS. WE WORK FOR CALAMP SO-
HELPING THEM. DISTRIBUTE
MEDICAL WHIPPET MEDICAL
LOGISTICS I'LL JUST MENTION A
FEW THINGS THAT WE SHIPPED
USING OUR MILITARY MANPOWER AND-
EQUITANT A FOUR POINT FIVE
MILLION MASKS. ABOUT THREE AND
A HALF MILLION TEST KITS OUT
ALMOST EIGHT HUNDRED
VENTILATORS. UNLESS A MILLION
GLOVES SELL THAT KIND OF
MEDICAL LOGISTICS SUPPORT TO
CALLEBS TO. AT THE DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH ASSETS TO
ASSIST THEM IN PROVIDING
SUPPORT FOR A TREATING.
PATIENTS THAT WERE FOR AT RISK
SO THIS IS A DIRECT MEDICAL
SUPPORT. 44% EIGHT AND FOURTEEN
COUNTIES WE CONTESTED SCREENED
OVER TWENTY THREE THOUSAND
PATIENTS AND THEN WE TREATED
ALMOST FORTY FIVE THOUSAND
PATIENTS. A SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES WHICH WERE KIND OF
AT THE EPICENTER OF THE
PANDEMIC IN TERMS OF. OF
CASUALTIES. AND THAT DANGEROUS
WORK CONTINUES TO THIS DAY
BEGAN IN MARCH CONTINUES TO
THIS DAY. AFTER THE CIVIL
DISTURBANCE AFTER THE KILLING
OF GEORGE FLOYD- THAT HAPPENED-
IN APPROXIMATELY THE END OF MAY
THROUGH EARLY JUNE. THANK THE
CALIFORNIA MILITARY DEPARTMENT
THE CALIFORNIA NATIONAL GUARD
DEPLOYED FIVE THOUSAND TROOPS
DIRECTLY IN SUPPORT OF BOTH
STATE AND LOCAL. LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES NEVER
LATELY WE WERE NEVER THE LEAD
AGENCY IN ANY OF THESE
OPERATIONS WE TOOK OUR ORDERS
DIRECTLY FROM. LAW ENFORCEMENT
AND WE HELPED SECURE A CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE AND PROVIDE A
SECURITY FOR THOSE
NEIGHBORHOODS THAT WERE
IMPACTED. THE LAST THING I'LL
TALK ABOUT IS- THE SUPPORT AT
THE END PRESIDENTE- WILDFIRE
SEASON THAT WE EXPERIENCED IN
TWENTY TWENTY. I'LL JUST GO
THROUGH SOME OF THE THESE FIRES
THAT MANY OF THESE WORKS HARD
AND ARE AMONG THE MOST DEADLY
AND DESTRUCTIVE FIRES IN THE
HISTORY OF THE STATE THE CREEK
FIRE IN SEPTEMBER. THE
CALIFORNIA MILITARY DEPARTMENT
PROVIDED HUNDRED TWENTY
PERSONNEL AT ELEVEN AIRCRAFT TO
CALIFORNIA WE DID. DO A UNIQUE
AT CIVILIAN EVACUATION MISSION
WHERE WE USE CHINOOK
HELICOPTERS AND BLACK HAWK
HELICOPTERS TO EVACUATE
APPROXIMATELY FOUR HUNDRED.
PERSONNEL AND TWENTY EIGHT
PAT'S FOR- A DANGEROUS
SITUATION WHICH THEY WERE
ENGULFED. BY FLAMES NEAR LAKE
IN IN FRESNO COUNTY. THE
COMPLEX FIRES THESE WERE THE.
FOR THE RECORD SETTING FIRES
THAT HAPPENED IN AUGUST THROUGH
OCTOBER TWENTY TWENTY WE AT WE
THE CALIFORNIA MILITARY
DEPLOYED A THIRTEEN HUNDRED
PERSONNEL MOSTLY IN HAND CREWS
TO THESE ARE PERSONAL
SUPPORTING CAL FIRE ON THE FIRE
LINES WE ALSO HAD SEVENTEEN
AIRCRAFT INVOLVED IN DROPPING
RETARDANT AND HAD WATER ON
THOSE FIRES THROUGHOUT THE
ENTIRE. EFFORT THE NORTH
COMPLEX FIRE THIS AUGUST
THROUGH DECEMBER TWENTY TWENTY
SIX LARGEST. IT NAB CALIFORNIA
HISTORY AND THE DEADLIEST OF
THE TWENTY TWENTY CALIFORNIA
WILDFIRE SEASON THAT WE DEPLOY
TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED PERSONNEL
AND TWENTY THREE AIRCRAFT FOR
THAT. FIRE AND- WITH THAT I
THINK ALL OF CLOSE BUT I'LL
REMIND. THE COMMITTEE THAT THE
YOU COULD FIND OUT MORE
INFORMATION ABOUT THE
CALIFORNIA MILITARY DEPARTMENT
IN THE CALIFORNIA NATIONAL
GUARD BY VISITING OUR FACEBOOK
PAGE. IT'S A FACEBOOK THE A
SLASH SEE A GUARD. AND THAT IS
A PROBABLY THE BEST WAY TO FIND
OUT MORE ABOUT THE DEPARTMENT
DO NEED SOME OF OUR SERVICE
MEMBERS THAT ARE RISKING THEIR
LIVES TO HELP CALIFORNIANS
TODAY AND I THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY. AND I'LL TURN IT
BACK OVER TO YOU. THANK YOU
BEFORE I OPEN IT UP TO
QUESTIONS DO WE HAVE ANY COMING
FROM ALEJO. SORT OF BORED
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE-
WE DID NOT RAISE ANY CONCERNS
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSALS FOR THE MILITARY
DEPARTMENT. THANK YOU ANY
QUESTIONS IN THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. NO MANAGER SO WAS BORN
DEPARTMENTS. FINANCE HAS NO
COMMENTS WITH THE PROPOSAL'S.
AT THANK YOU I DON'T ANY
QUESTIONS I HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
SEE YOUR SERVICEMEN AND WOMEN
AT THE FOOD BANK IN MY DISTRICT
THEY APPRECIATE THE SERVICE
THAT I'M PROVIDING YEAR ROUND-
TO US AND I WAS TRACKING THE
FIRES AND THAT LAKE BUSKING
FRESNO COUNTY- I HAD FOLKS OUT
THERE THAT I KNEW. I IS A TO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE IT
HAS BEEN AN EXTRAORDINARY YEAR
FOR ALL OF US I AND YOUR
SERVICE MEN AND WOMEN HAVE BEEN
RISKING THEIR LIVES YEAR ROUND
SO IT'S JUST WANNA THANK YOU
FOR THAT MY COLLEAGUES HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS ON THE FIRST ISSUE.
OKAY ONE THING THAT WE HAVE AN
ORAL. COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS ON
THE FIRST ISSUE I'M GONNA GO
AHEAD AND MOVE ON TO ISSUE
NUMBER TWO. FOR ISSUE NUMBER
TWO THE PANELIST- WILL BE
REVIEWING- YES AS- VARIAS.
ALREADY ON VARIOUS BUDGET
PROPOSALS. M. S. THIRTY S.
PROVIDE AN OVERVIEW OF THE ROLE
INCLUDING MANY PROGRAMS AND
INITIATIVES IN ADDRESSING
CLIMATE CHANGE ISSUES. AND THE
STATE. THEY WILL GET AT SELECT
HIGHLIGHTS OF THE BUDGET
PROPOSAL SUBMITTED TO THE
OFFICE. PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME
WHEN YOU BEGAN. WE CAN GO AHEAD
AND BEGIN THE FIRST PANEL. HI
GOOD AFTERNOON JERRY GARCIA AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
TINA CURRY AND I'M THE CHIEF
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF OPERATIONS
CORRECT HELLO YES. I'M GONNA
KEEP THIS OFF- WITH SOME BRIEF
OPENING REMARKS ABOUT THE ROLE
OF OUR AGENCY AND THEN I HAVE
OTHER COLLEAGUES HERE. THAT
WILL BE ABLE 2% MORE IN DETAIL
AND YOUR QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
BUDGET PROPOSAL READY FOR
TODAY- APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE A BRIEF
OVERVIEW OF OUR
RESPONSIBILITIES ARE FOR
OFFICE. WHICH ENSURE OUR THAT
WE ARE THE STATE AGENCY
RESPONSIBLE FOR MITIGATING
EFFECTS OF DISASTERS AND
PROTECTING LIVES AND PROPERTY
YEAH CALIFORNIANS WINNERS
EVENTS OCCUR. UNDER THE
AUTHORITIES OF THE EMERGENCY
SERVICES ACT PROBABLY YES
REALLY ACCESS THE HUB OF
COORDINATION FOR THE ENTIRE
STATE AGENCY. ORGANIZATION AND
HOW THAT COMES TOGETHER TO
RESPOND TO COMMUNITIES AND GET
THE RESPONDENT DISASTERS IN THE
NEEDS OF OUR COMMUNITY FOR ALSO
THE ORGANIZERS OF OUR STATEWIDE
MUTUAL AID SYSTEM AND SO THAT
IS A NEIGHBOR HELPING NEIGHBOR
PROGRAM THAT WE HAD HERE IN
CALIFORNIA FOR SOME TIME THAT
ALLOWS US TO SEARCH. RESOURCES
SUCH AS FIRE DEPARTMENTS LAW
ENFORCEMENT INTO AREAS OF NEED.
DURING AT EVERY DISASTER TO
READ WHEN IT'S WHEN A COMMUNITY
HAS IS THAT UNABLE TO MEET THE
NEEDS OF THAT STUFF AND STUFF
HAVE AN EVENT THAT MIGHT BE
HAPPENING. WE HAVE A NUMBER OF
LINES OF EFFORT THAT MAKE UP
OUR ORGANIZATION DEREK HELLO
YES AND TO BUILD BUILDINGS
RESPONSIBILITIES. NOT INCLUDES
BOTH RESPONSE AND RECOVERY SO
MISSION AS WELL AS THE- KIND OF
BACK AND IF YOU WILL I'VE KIND
OF RECOVERY AND FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE TO COMMUNITIES
FOLLOWING DISASTERS AND
EMERGENCIES. WE HAVE A PROGRAM
THAT MAKES INVESTMENTS INTO
WHAT WE CALL MITIGATION AND
RISK REDUCTION. WE'VE GOT SO IT
HAD A LOT OF GRANT MANAGEMENT
THAT THE BILLIONS OF FIVE
DOLLARS AND YEN THAT IMPOSTOR
MONEY WE HAVE A HOMELAND
SECURITY AND CYBERSECURITY
PROGRAM IT OVER YES AND FINALLY
WE. ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR
STATEWIDE- MERCHANTS THEY PLAY
AS WELL AS TRAIN WHATEVER
PERSONAL. AND MANAGEMENT.
COMMUNITIES THE STATE. FIRST
SYSTEM WE USE TO DO ALL OF THAT
HAS BEEN AN PLACE FOR.
CALIFORNIA AND MAKE SURE THE
STATE EFFORTS CENTRAL IN
UNIFIED WHEN WE ARE HELPING OUR
COMMUNITY FOR THE- THIS RAIN
FROM THE METRO THIS THAT I HARD
MENTIONED. OUR STAY OPERATIONS
WHICH IS THE HUB THE FOR THE
LOOK. WHERE ALL STATE FIRST
COMES TOGETHER TO SUPPORT. OUR
COMMUNITIES WHEN SOMETHING
HAPPENS. AND THE CAMPAIGNING OF
THE CABINET AGENCIES UNDER
SOMETHING CALLED THE UNIFIED
COORDINATION GROUP TO MAKE SURE
THERE'S CONFUSION. AND AND THE
UNITY OF EFFORT AMONGST THE
STATE FAMILY. AND THEN ALSO
TASKING STATE AGENCIES UNDER
WHAT WE CALL MISSION TASKING
WHEN THERE'S AN ASSIGNMENT OR
PROBLEM. THAT NEEDS TO BE
ATTENDED TO HER NO BETTER
MENTION JUST A FEW OF THEM WITH
NATIONAL GUARD. MISSION SETS
THAT WE WORK WITH THEM JUST
JUST IN THE PAST YEAR. TO
FACILITATE. IT'S VERY TO CRY
ALL THE OF IN THIS. THAT EVERY
CITY EVERY COUNTY BUT TO THE
STATE IN ORGANIZING THE SAME
WAY. SO THAT- YOU KNOW
HOPEFULLY ISSUES ARE HANDLED AT
AT AT AT A LOCAL LEVEL BUT
THERE'S A COMMON ORGANIZATION
IN PLACE WHEN WE QUICKLY AND
OFTEN DO. HAVE TO MOBILIZE
STATE RESOURCES TO HELP OUT-
YES ARE THE UNIQUE ROLE OF
UNDERSTANDING CAPABILITIES
ACROSS GOVERNMENT AND THE
PRIVATE SECTOR. AND SOMETHING
THAT WERE CUSTOM TO BECAUSE OF
ALL OF THE DIFFERENT KINDS OF
HAZARDS THAT CALIFORNIA
SENSUALLY AND DOES FACE. EACH.
AND EVERY YEAR. AND THEN WE
DEPLOY. SHARING OF AND FOR
PROBLEM SOLVING. I OUTLINED IT
WILL BE THE STATE NUMBER PLAN.
WHICH NOT ONLY. THE AMERICAN
REGISTRY ORGANISING FOR HELPING
WORKING. HELPING COME TOGETHER
AND DECIDE. BUT ALSO LAYS OUT
THE IN THE- IN VARIOUS AGENCIES
THAT THE PROBLEM INTEREST. HOW
THE STATE FAMILY COMES TO. AS
AS AS DEPRIVE AND. SO YOU KNOW
IN SINCE EARLY IN FOUR LIKE
EVER ELSE THAT CAL. HAS BEEN
INVOLVED IN THE- RESPONSE.
WE'VE WAITED ROLAND FOR NEEDING-
THE RESPONSE EVER OF THE STATE
APPLE- THAT. OUR NURSE WITH
HEALTH AND HUMAN. IN THE-
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH.
AND THEN OF IN THE OF THEM.
CALIFORNIA BASED ANOTHER- EMAIL
JUST ARE FIRES. AND AS WE HAVE
FOR NUMBER YEARS AND THE WAY WE
ABLE TO. ALL OF THAT TO PLUS
PLUS THE OF IT IS THE THAT
HAPPEN IN TWENTY. WEST BECAUSE
OF THEM WERE. THAT WOULD CAP A
STRONG. THIS YOU KNOW THE THIS
WAY OF COMING IN MAKING SURE
STATE RESOURCES ALWAYS POINTED
WAY THAT. IS DEALING WITH
WHATEVER THEY HAVE THE NEED. IS
THERE YEAH. WE ALSO HAVE YOUR
ROLE AS- ACCESS. TO THE-
GOVERNMENT FOR. SERVICES
QUESTION THAT IT OF THREE. THAT
WE NEED. FOR THE FEDERAL. IF WE
NEED. AND CARBON THE FED OR
ANOTHER FOR. AGENCY TO RESPOND.
THAT PATHWAY IS THROUGH
CALLAWAY S. AS WELL SO WE'RE
HELPING LOCAL GOVERNMENT WITH
STATE RESOURCES AND WE'RE ALSO
ABLE TO ASK. FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. AND FOR THE FOR THE
SAME TYPE THEIR ORGANIZED THE
SAME WAY. WE ALSO PLAY A ROLE
AS A METHOD OF ACCESS IN TERMS
OF THE FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE
THAT COMES. COMES IN PLAY
INVOLVING THE **** FROM THE
FEDERAL EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT
AGENCY ARE ENOUGH. THAT WE ARE
THE OFFICE THE FACILITATES. THE
REIMBURSEMENT OF DISASTER COSTS
WITH THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS
INVOLVED- PRESIDENTIAL DISASTER
DECLARATION. SO NOT JUST FOR
COVER THE FOR WHAT WILDFIRES OR
EARTHQUAKES. PLANTED CENTER ARE.
THE WITHOUT THAT'S JUST VERY
MUCH AND I AND THAT'S WAY HELLO
DOES THE POWER. MAKING WE HE
TALKED OR CALL ABOUT HER GOOD
FOR BY DIFFERENT. YOU KNOW.
KIND OF SEE AN KNOW PLAY OF ALL
THE THOSE DIFFERENT ELEMENTS.
BUT I DO WANT TO TALK A LITTLE
BIT ON THE YOU AND I ABOUT OUR
pOUT. AND I THINK IT YOU KNOW
GOES WITHOUT SAYING THAT THESE
CLIMATE OR PREVENTHAZARDS CAN
TAKE INTO PERSISTENT.
CALIFORNIA AN IMPACT OR STATE
WITH GREATER FREQUENCY AND-
CONSEQUENCE. OF LAST YEAR'S
FIRE SEASON- EXCEEDED YOUR
RECORD IN TERMS OF THE HISTORIC
NATURE AND ALL INDICATORS ARE
THAT. I'M JUST AND THAT ONE
CASE THAT WE'RE GOING TO NEED
TO SEE. REALLY I'M SIGNIFICANT
CONSEQUENCES FOR WILDFIRES. SO
WITH THAT WE HAVE CONSIDER
CLIMATE CHANGE IN OUR
CALIFORNIA'S RISK REDUCTION
STRATEGY. SINCE WAY BACK YOU
KNOW IN THAT- YEAH TWO THOUSAND
AND SEVEN- YOU KNOW THAT'S KIND
OF ONE OF THE EARLIEST POINTS
WHEN OUR STATE WILL BE COLOR
STATE HAZARD MITIGATION PLAN
WHICH IS AT RISK REDUCTION
STRATEGY HAS REFLECTED WHAT WE
NEED WITH THE TIME. ABOUT
CLIMATE CHANGE CLIMATE
ADAPTATION AND EVER SINCE THEN
AND NOW WE'RE HERE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. THAT HAS MATURED-
MARWAR S. YEAH THAT IS MORE
SCIENCE MORE DATA BECAME
AVAILABLE ON THE WAIT REASON
THAT'S IMPORTANT OUR STATE
MITIGATION PLAN. IT'S ACTUALLY
THE DRIVER FOR HOW WE INVEST IN
RISK REDUCTION AND RESILIENCE
IN CALIFORNIA SO THE DIRECT
CORRELATION. TO BE ABROGATED
INFORMATION THAT'S IN THE
PLANT. INTO HOW WE PRIORITIZE
AND. INVEST IN EDUCATION. FOR
MEMBER OF ALL THE FOR THAT MAKE
UP TO MAKE UP OF THE STATE.
CLIMATE ADAPTATION. AND
RECENTLY WE PUBLISHED ENACTED
TO SOME CALLED THE STATE.
ADAPTATION GUIDE THIS IS SOME
THAT TO US THREE ALLEGE. I
THINK I TWENTY. AND REQUIRES A
TO LOOK AT THE STATE THAT A
PATIENT STRATEGY AND MAKE SURE
THAT WE- TOOL KIT IF YOU WILL.
OUR COMMUNITY OF. AND CALLED TO
BE ABLE TO INCORPORATE THE
LATEST SCIENCE IN PLACE
PLANNING TAKES. WHO CLIMATE
ADAPTATION. PLANETS REALLY HOW
TO. STOP BASED GUIDE FOR
COMMUNITIES AS ONE EXAM- BUT
SUFFICE TO SAY THAT CLIMATE
CHANGE CLIMATE ADAPTATION IS.
SOMETHING THAT IS AT THE
FOREFRONT. OF OUR PLANNING
STRATEGIES YOUR IT AND- YES
AND- FOR BOTH RISK REDUCTION AS
WELL AS FOR EMERGENCY PLANNING
AND WILL CONTINUE TO BE. GOING
FORWARD IS THAT IS THAT THERE'S
A VICIOUS PERSON. SO WITH THAT
THAT'S JUST REALLY A VERY HIGH
LEVEL OVER AND OVER YOU THAT
HOPEFULLY YEAH- ANSWERS SOME OF
YOUR QUESTIONS AND HAPPY TO
ANSWER MORE AND I'LL TURN IT
OVER TO MY COLLEAGUES TO
PERCENT. THE. DIFFERENCE BUDGET
EITHER. THE NAME OF CHAIRMAN OF
THE PUBLIC CORE OF. ONE WITH
THAT HELLO YES AND I'M JUST
GIVE YOU HIGH LEVEL OF SOME OF
THE TALKS. PROPOSAL THAT WERE
INCLUDED IN THE GOVERNOR BUDGET
FOR CALLING WE- AND THEN WE
HAVE- SOME OF OUR SUBJECT
MATTER. EXPERTS IN THE ROOM I
CAN HELP IT ANY. QUESTIONS THAT
YOU MIGHT HAVE. THE FIRST IN
YOUR DONE THE LIKE HOW.
DISTRICT THE THIRD. ACT WE
REFERRED IT AS THE- WHAT DOES
THE OF THE- THIS IS THE ACT
THAT GIVES THE- DEPARTMENT THE
AT. TO HAVE THE DISASTER
ASSISTANCE PRORAM WHAT WE DO
WITHOUT AS WE ADMINISTER THIS
PROGRAM FOR THE LOCALS WHO AND-
HAVE HAD- ZASTROW EVENTS THAT.
LED TO. PROPERTY DAMAGE OR
INFRASTRUCTURAL LOST AND WE ARE
ABLE TO KIND OF USE THIS
APPROPRIATION TO HELP EITHER
PAY FOR SOME OF THE LOCAL COST
OR TO HELP MEET FEDERAL
MATCHES- FOR FEDERALLY DECLARED
DISASTERS LIKE- THAT WOULD
STILL BE MATH YOU HAD MENTIONED
BEFORE. EVERY YEAR WE GO
THROUGH AND WE LOOK AT WHAT THE
LOCALS ARE ENTITLED TO OUR OWN
FOR THEIR VARIOUS- DAMAGED.
GOODS AND SERVICES AND THEN
WHAT WE DO IS WE DO A
PROJECTION OF HOW MUCH NEEDS TO
GO OUT ON ANY GIVEN YEAR SO WE
KIND OF LOOK AT IT BY FISCAL
YEAR WHAT'S OWED FOR. EACH
DISASTER EVENT THAT WE'RE
THRILLED THAT BROKE- SO BORED
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET WE HAD AN
INITIAL PROPOSAL OF ABOUT TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY SIX POINT ONE
MILLION WE HAVE A BASE BUDGET
OF ABOUT SIXTY TWO POINT SIX
MILLION. SO THE INCREASE IS
REALLY RELATED TO A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT THINGS INCLUDING-
COVETED RESPONSES LIKE THE
GREAT PLAINS PROGRAM AND WHAT
WAS ESTIMATED IN THE CURRENT
NINETEEN ESTIMATE CHART THAT
WAS PROVIDED THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET. IT ALSO HAS SOME
RESERVE GIVEN THAT WE HAVE SOME
CONTINUED UNCERTAINTY AND- AND-
HEART. UNCERTAINTY OF THIS
PANDEMIC SO WHAT WE DO IS WE
WILL GO THROUGH AND DO ANOTHER
UPDATE IN THE SPRING. TO GO
BACK AND LOOK AT ANY OF THE-
UPDATES THAT WE HAVE A GREAT
ACOSTA CO THAT ANY NEW
DISASTERS ANY PROJECT UPDATES
OR ANY CHANGES TO THE FEDERAL
REIMBURSEMENT SCHEDULE THAT
WOULD AFFECT HOW MUCH IS NEEDED.
FOR A LOCAL REIMBURSEMENT. BUT
NEXT INCLUDED IN YOUR AGENDA IS
THE- EARLY EARTH. WARNINGS INTO
SIXTEEN. WE'VE HAD A COUPLE OF
INFO OF THE- TO BUILD OUT A PRO.
THAT IS TO SUPPORT UP. AND
OUTREACH CAMPAIGN RESEARCH AND
DEVELOPMENT AND TO EXPAND
MEDICATION USES AND PROGRAM
MANAGEMENT FOR THE CALIFORNIA
EARTHQUAKE EARLY WARNING
PROGRAM- WE HAD SOME ONE TIME
FUNDING PROVIDED IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. SO THIS IS A
REQUEST TO ASK FOR SEVENTEEN
POINT THREE MILLION TO CONTINUE
THE EXPANSION OF THE PROGRAM
AND FINISH BUILDING OUT OF THE
SYSTEM- THE NEXT. PROPOSAL IS
THE NEXT GENERATION GRANT
PROGRAM- THIS PROGRAM HAS BEEN
AROUND FOR A COUPLE OF YEARS WE
RECEIVED OR NOT THE PROGRAM BUT
THE GRANTED STUFF WE RECEIVED A
FEDERAL. YOUR OUR NINE ONE ONE
SO THEY CALL IT NEXT GENERATION
BASICALLY THE GREAT FUNDS ARE
USED TO- EXPAND. HELPER NINE
ONE ONE CALL DISPATCHERS USE
DIGITAL INTERNET PROTOCOLS AND
BROAD BASED THE NAVAL
TECHNOLOGIES AND MAKE SURE THAT
WE CAN COORDINATE EMERGENCY
RESPONSE. BECAUSE THE FOR THE
FEDERAL SOURCE WE WERE ABLE TO
ENCUMBER OR MAKE A PROMISE OR
COMMITMENT FOR ALL OF OUR LOCAL
SUBSISTENCE GRANTS THAT ARE OUT
IN THE FIELD HOWEVER WE STILL
NEED SOME EXTRA SUPPORT AT THE
STATE LEVEL TO ENSURE THAT
WERE- MAKE MOVES THAT WE'RE
MAKING ALL OF OUR- MEETING ALL
OF OUR COMMITMENTS- FOR THE
MONITORING OF THE PROGRAM THE
USE OF THE FUNDS SO THIS IS
JUST A REQUEST TO EXTEND FOR
ANOTHER YEAR. THE USE OF THOSE.
MONIES AT THE STATE LEVEL. THE
FINAL. THAT YOU HAVE- I THINK
THAT IS THE PROPOSED. SO
THERE'S A COUPLE OTHER PAPA THE
NINE- I THINK THE LATER OUT
FAIRLY WELL THERE SOME- ONE
TIME. THE. FOR- THE FIRST. AS
WELL AS PROPERTY OUTLAY AND-
PROJECTS I'M I'M NOT GONNA
BELABORED BUT WE DO HAVE A THE
X. IN THE ROOM IF YOU HAVE ANY.
PROGRAM ON THE- OF THE OTHER
PROJECTS. OH WAIT I GOODNESS
ONE SORRY THE REGIONAL HAS MANY.
BY SO THE REASON HAPPEN THIS
MATURE RISK. THE PROGRAM THAT
WAS. IN TWENTY. WE RECEIVED
PERMANENT POSITIONS IN SOME
LIMITED TERM FUNDING. FOR THIS
PROGRAM THAT REALLY IS THE
SUPPORT OF SUCH A HAZARDOUS
MATERIAL RESPONSE CAPABILITIES
TO LOCAL FIRE DEPARTMENTS-
WHICH ARE NOT WHICH THEY'RE NOT
NECESSARILY EQUIPPED TO FIND.
SO WHAT WE'RE ASKING FOR THE
CONTINUATION OF THAT PROGRAM
AND NOT REQUESTED FOR THREE
SIX. THREE POINT SIX MILLION.
AND I THOUGHT I WILL OPEN UP TO
ANY QUESTIONS OR IF THERE'S-
ANY PROGRAM DETAILS THAT. I
WOULD LIKE TO OKAY ON. THANK
BEFORE I OPENED AN UP TO PAY OF
HAVE ANY FROM. TRUE SORT OF
BORED LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE WE DID NOT RAISE ANY
CONCERNS WITH THESE PROPOSALS.
THANK YOU AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. I ENDED UP THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NOTHING
ELSE TO ADD THANK YOU. THANK
YOU I HAVE A COUPLE QUESTIONS A
PERSON'S ABOUT THE EARLY
EARTHQUAKE WARNING SYSTEM I
KNOW THAT YOU'RE FINISHING UP A
COST BENEFIT ANALYSIS REPORT.
DO YOU HAVE AN APPROXIMATE
APPROXIMATE APPROXIMATION OF
WHEN THAT MIGHT BE AVAILABLE.
THANK YOU YEAH YOU DIRECTOR
PLANNING PREPAREDNESS AND
PREVENTION- YES WE ARE
FINALIZING THAT- WE HAVE BEEN
NOT. TRYING TO DO THAT IN
TANDEM WITH A LOT OF OUR- OKAY
NINETEEN AND VACCINE OPERATIONS
ARE- AND WE ARE CLOSE TO
FINALIZING DON'T HAVE A CERTAIN
FOR YOU AT THIS TIME. OKAY AND
THEN DO WE HAVE ANY ESTIMATIONS
OF WHEN WE WHEN WE DO GET THE
FINAL PROPOSAL HOW IT'S GOING
TO BE FUNDED LONG TERM. THAT IS
ALSO SOMETHING THAT WE'RE
WORKING ON- WE'VE LOOKED INTO A
COUPLE POSSIBILITIES I WORK FOR
PUTTING THIS TOGETHER IN A
PROPOSAL FOR YOU- AND- I HAVE
AGAIN HAVE NO DATE CERTAIN ON
WHEN WE WILL BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
THAT FOR YOU. T. APPROXIMATE
THAT THE SUMP MIGHT BE
AVAILABLE BEFORE THE MAY REVISE
OR AFTER THE MAY REVIVE. I
DON'T HAVE AN ANSWER TO THAT- I
DON'T KNOW IF THERE HAS ANY
FOLLOW UP ON THAT. OKAY YOU CAN
FOLLOW OF DOLLARS UP. YOU CAN
FOLLOW UP WITH YOU LATER SO YOU
CAN. THIS IS HEATHER CARLSON-
AGAIN WE'RE WORK TO HAVE
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE PART OF
FINANCE AND LOOKING FOR OTHER
VIABLE FUND SOURCES FOR- THE
ONGOING COMMITMENT FOR THIS
PROGRAM. OKAY I LOOK FORWARD TO
SOME INFORMATION- DOWN DOWN THE
ROAD I KNOW THE ONGOING
DISCUSSION AND- WERE HAVING TO
MANAGE- THE ONGOING
EMERGENCIES. PLUS THE CONTINUED
OR IF YOU WERE ALREADY DOING-
BUT I DO I DO HOPE WE GET THAT
INFORMATION IN THE NEAR FUTURE.
MY SECOND QUESTION IS. ABOUT
CLIMATE CHANGE AND THE RISK
REDUCTION AND MITIGATION I'M
HIDING THAT YOU'RE DOING
SPECIFICALLY GET AROUND OUR-
MOST VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES.
AND YOU HAVE EXPERTISE I HAVE
FOR EXAMPLE I HAVE NINE SMALL
CITIES. OF THAT OUR CONTRACT
CITIES AND SO THAT I HAVE A LOT
OF THEIR OWN EXPERTISE AND-
UNLESS THAT THEY'RE ALWAYS
PLANNING AHEAD. AND THEN THERE
IS MITIGATION- OUT THERE AND SO
ARE THERE WAYS IN WHICH YOU'RE
WORKING WITH THESE SMALLER
CITIES YOU MIGHT NOT HAVE THE
ABILITIES TO BE RE REDUCING
RISK THE MITIGATION. SO THAT
WHEN WE DO HAVE AN EMERGENCY
WE'RE BETTER PREPARED AND- IT'S
LESS COSTLY OR YOUR JOB IS A
LITTLE BIT EASIER. YEAH THANK
YOU FOR THAT QUESTION CAN A
CURRY AGAIN FROM HELLO YES AND-
WE ARE NOT VERY HARD TO
MITIGATION PLAN I MENTIONED
IDENTIFIED- UNITY
VULNERABILITIES BOTH BY
DISASTER RISK AND ALSO SOCIO
ECONOMIC. VULNERABILITY
THROUGHOUT THE WE HAVE THAT AS
A MEMBER BASS LINE PLANNING
pGREATEST NEEDS ARE. AND WE HAVE
A TEAM OF ABOUT FOLKS THAT
WHOSE JOB IT IS TO. WORK WITH
COMMUNITIES TO THEIR OUT REACH
IT IS CHALLENGING AS YOU
MENTIONED FOR COMMUNITIES TO BE
READY FOR YOU KNOW THE NINETIES
BRANDS CAN BE COMPLEX. REALLY
HAVE TO HAVE A LOT OF PEOPLE
LINE UP IN ORDER TO. DO TO BE
ABLE TO ADD YOUR TAKE THE FUNDS
TO BE ABLE TO EXPAND THEM SO
THAT IS A BIG FOCUS OF. EFFORT
OF OURS AND I KNOW THERE'S
ALWAYS MORE THAT WE COULD DO.
AND CERTAINLY IF THEY WERE-
CERTAIN SPECIFIC. IMMUNITY HAVE
QUESTIONS ABOUT OR THAT HAVE
YOU KNOW IDEAS OR THINGS ARE
LIKELY TO BE FUNDED WE CAN WORK
WITH ME. ON THOSE DETAILS AND
FOLLOW UP ON THAT SPECIFIC
ABOUT. WHAT WE CAN. YEAH I MEAN
IT IS THINK IN GENERAL AND A WE
SEE IT WITH THE- OR NOW SIR
COMMUTER. ARE WE HAD WE WERE
TALKING A EQUITY INSERTING. ARE
BEING HIT HARDER AND ARE. ARE
DEALING WITH ITS WITH THE CAR.
A LITTLE BIT HARD AND IT'S BEEN
A FOR THEM MOVE FOR TO MAKE
PROGRESS. NOT BECAUSE THE
PANDEMIC HAS CREATED THIS
INEQUITIES BUT- BECAUSE THEY
BELIEVE THEY BELONG ROOTED AND
SO. I'VE I'VE THESE MOMENTS
PROVIDE US THE OPPORTUNITY TO
REMEMBER THAT THERE'S WORK WE
COULD BE DOING AHEAD OF TIME
AND- SOMETIMES I KNOW WE NEED A
HOPPER SOUTHEAST COMMUNITY
SENSE AS WE NEED FOLKS TO HELP
US. OF BE BE READY FOR THAT YOU
READY FOR THAT MOMENT- AS WELL
AND SO. YOU KNOW JUST AS WE
LOOK AT OUR MOST VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES WHETHER IS TO THE-
HEALTHY COMMUNITY INDEX OR THAT
THE CALAVERAS WIENER. I WOULD
SAY THAT YOU KNOW OFTENTIMES
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR NON
COMMUNITIES I HAPPEN TO
REPRESENT. A CHUNK OF THOSE L.
A. COUNTY BUT I'M NOT THE ONLY
AREA RIGHT SO WHAT I WOULD WANT
TO ADVOCATE FOR MY DISTRICT BY
WITH AFFAIR AND- JUST KIND OF
IN GENERAL THESE COMMUNITIES
ARE. ARE IMPORTANT AS WE'RE
LOOKING AT. ONE OF THE
COMMUNITIES ON THE ROAD WITH
CLIMATE CHANGE. I IN PARTICULAR
AS WE THINK ABOUT THE- BOTH THE
HEAT ISLAND EFFECT OR THE FACT
THAT THESE TOXIC SKIP BAKED AND
BECOME MORE TOXIC- DURING
THESE. HIGH HEAT MOMENTS THAT
ARE RELATED TO CLIMATE CHANGE
UP AND. SO- IN THE FUTURE WHICH
IS TO BE ABLE TO EXPAND ON THAT
THIS GUY. THANK YOU FOR THAT
THE- RIGHT OUT WITH THAT I'M
GONNA HAVE TO OVER TO MICHAEL-
MY BUT A LOT IS. HI THANK YOU
SO MUCH- FOR SPEAKING ON THESE
TODAY. MY QUESTIONS ARE
ACTUALLY ARE ACTUALLY AS MISS
CURRY REFERENCE EARLIER
WILDFIRE SEASON- IS JUST THAT
IT'S THE SEASON THAT DOESN'T
END AND THE IMPACTS WE HAVE
SEEN IN OUR COMMUNITIES. OVER
THE PAST YEARS IS GROWING AND
PART OF THE MITIGATION EFFORTS
INCLUDE PS PS EVENTS- WHICH IN
MY COMMUNITY SEEM TO HAPPEN
VERY FREQUENTLY. AND MY
QUESTION- COOLEY FOR THE PAST
TWO YEARS HELLO YES HAS
ADMINISTERED OVER. A HUNDRED
AND TWENTY FIVE MILLION TO HELP
COMMUNITIES MITIGATE THE
SIGNIFICANT IMPACTS. OF POWER
OUTAGES SO I WAS PARTICULARLY
FRUSTRATED AND ACTUALLY UPSET
TO SEE THAT AND THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED BUT BUDGET. HE
ELIMINATED GROUNDS- FOR SPECIAL
DISTRICTS TRIBES BOMB AND
CITIES TO. APPLY FOR THESE
GRANTS AND- I'VE HEARD FROM
SEVERAL DISTRICTS AND CITIES IN
MY COMMUNITY- WHO SAY THAT THIS
IS JUST A DROP IN THE BUCKET
AND MY COMMUNITY. I HAVE
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE
THAT ARE AFFECTED BY PS PS
EVENTS EVENTS. AT N. IN. IN THE
MOST THE MOST FRUSTRATING WAY
AS A MATTER OF FACT I WAS-
THERE WAS A FACEBOOK VIDEO OF A
MAN AN INTERSECTION A DARK
INTERSECTION ONE OF MY CITIES.
AND SIX CARS BLEW PAST THIS
DARK INTERSECTION BECAUSE THEY
COULDN'T TELL ON THAT- THERE
WAS A STOP LIKE THERE THAT
WOULD TYPICALLY BE. ON IF THE
POWER WAS ON AND THERE WAS AN
ACCIDENT ACTUALLY IN IN THAT
VIDEO THERE'S A HUGE NEED SO
MIKE MY QUESTION IS. FROM IS TO
CARILLO YES IS HOW MANY CITIES
SPECIAL DISTRICTS AND TRIBES
APPLIED FOR FUNDING AND WERE
DENIED IN EITHER. TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN. OR TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY. THE CARD FOR THE
CALORIE AS WE CAN GET THAT
SPECIFIC INFORMATION BACK TO
YOU WE DO HAVE IT I JUST DON'T
HAVE IT AT MY- I THINK THAT. I
WOULD BE THAT AND THEN MY NEXT
QUESTION IS BOTH FOR. HELLO YES
IN THE ALLEY LA JOH CLEARLY
THERE'S A DEMAND FOR THESE
FUNDS- I'D LIKE TO KNOW WHETHER
ONLY AFTER THE ALLEY- BELIEVES
RESTORING THESE FUNDS WOULD BE
BENEFICIAL TO ENSURING. THE
PREPAREDNESS OF THESE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AGAINST PF PF
EVENTS. SORT OF BORED
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
ON V. P. S. P. S. FUNDS
PROVIDED TO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
ABOUT CERTAINLY MORE. ENABLE
THEM TO- BETTER RESPOND TO
THESE POWER SHUT DOWN EVENTS
OVER THE LEGISLATURE WILL NEED
TO EVALUATE. THAT AGAINST ITS
OTHER GENERAL FUND PRIORITIES
EITHER DECIDES HOW MUCH
FUNDING. RIGHT IN THIS AREA.
HELLO YES. THE OTHER WAY WE
CONTINUE TO BE SUPPORTIVE OF.
BUT THE GOVERNMENT WE'RE HAPPY
TO PROVIDE ANY ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION FOR AND I'D
ACTUALLY LIKE TO THANK YOU FOR
THAT I'D ACTUALLY LIKE TO ASK
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE BUT
THERE'S A REASON WHY- THAT THIS
WAS CUT OUT OF THE BUDGET THIS
YEAR BUT IT ELIMINATED- WANTED
SOMETHING THAT IS GROWING IN
FREQUENCY. NOT DIMINISHING. HI
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER I
ENDED UP THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE- SOMEONE TWENTY
NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE MILLION
WAS PROVIDED ON A ONE TIME
BASIS- AGAIN IN TWENTY TWENTY
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS- FIFTEEN
ON GENERAL FUND WHICH PROVIDE
ONE TIME- AS YOU KNOW. FUNDING
WAS NOT PROPOSES THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET WE DO
CONTINUE TO TRACK THE IMPACTS
OF BEST BE DISPENSING AND
ACTIONS TAKEN BY A UTILITIES
AND LOCAL ENTITIES- ALSO
ADMINISTRATION IS WORKING
DILIGENTLY TO GET THE-
REMAINDER OF THE FUNDING. OUT
MAKE SURE THAT WE KNOW. WHERE
IT'S GOING AND- MAKING SURE
IT'S IMPACTFUL. WITH A VERY
SEPARATE SACRAMENTO PROGRESS
INITIATION ADDED- DETERMINATION
NOT TO. PROPOSE ADDITIONAL
PREPARATIONS AT THIS TIME FOR
ABOUT TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY
START. TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO OF
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. THANK
YOU. IS THE DANCER. HI ACTUALLY
THIS IS VERY FAMILIAR TO ME-
AND BEFORE COMING TO
LEGISLATURE I WAS OF FLOOR
WARDEN COMMUNITY COORDINATOR
BILL EMERGED COORDINATOR AND
EMERGENCY PERNICE COORDINATOR
FOR THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES AND
MY QUESTION IS REALLY ABOUT
THAT THE KIND OF DOVETAILS WITH
THE TWO CHAIRMEN WOMAN IS
TALKING ABOUT HOW YOU GET
COMMUNITIES PREPARED FOR
DISASTERS AND I REMEMBER THE
DISASTER ACTION PLANS. ANDY THE
FORWARD MANUALS IN THE BUILDING
MERGING PREPAREDNESS
COORDINATOR MANUALS- IN
NINETEEN NINETY THEY DID NOT
HAVE THINGS LIKE CIVIL UNREST.
IN NINETEEN NINETY THEY DID NOT
HAVE THINGS LIKE WILDFIRES THEY
DID HAVE PARAGRAPHS ABOUT IT
BUT IT WAS A PARAGRAPH. I'M
PRETTY SURE IS PAGES AND PAGES
AND PAGES OF COLLEGE THERE. NOW
WE'RE IN A PANDEMIC. AND WE
HAVE TO ADJUST AND I KNOW
MORTON PROBABLY BETTER THAN
ANYBODY ELSE YOU CAN ALWAYS
PLAN. FOR A MAJOR DISASTER BUT
YOU NEED TO ADAPT- FOR EXAMPLE
WE WORKED ON. ON THE WHITTIER
EARTHQUAKE AND SEVERAL OTHER IT
GRAYSON WINNER NORTHRIDGE HER
HAPPEN EARTHQUAKE HAPPENED IN
LOS ANGELES WE'RE BETTER
EQUIPPED AT HANDLING IT AND WE
WERE ABLE TO GET OUT OF THAT
DISASTER FAIRLY QUICKLY BECAUSE
WE HAVE HAD EXPERIENCE. AND SO.
I JUST WANNA KNOW THAT WHOLE IT
WAS LIKE A WHOLE INFRASTRUCTURE
OF TRAINING CITIES OR HOW TO
DEAL WITH DISASTERS WE HAD A
TRAINING CENTER I BELIEVE NEAR
SAN LUIS OBISPO. AND I EVEN
WENT TO THE TO THE NATIONAL
EMERGENCY TRAINING CENTER IN
EMMITSBURG- MARYLAND I'M NOT
SUE IF THEY'RE STILL THERE. MY
AGE IS PROBABLY PRE DATING MAN
WHAT WAS GOING ON SO I WOULD
LIKE TO KNOW. DO WE STILL. HAVE
OR DO WE STILL REQUIRE. LOW
MINISTER. TO CREATE DISASTER
PLANS DECREASED DISASTER
MANUALS TO BE READY FOR JUST
ABOUT ANYTHING BECAUSE WHO KNEW
ABOUT A PANDEMIC. M. AND BEING
A WOULD BE PREPARED TO HANDLE
THAT AND ON TOP OF THAT- I'M SO
YOU KNOW THERE'S A LOT OF
GRANTS AND MONEYS- I WAS IN
CHARGE OF ENSURING THAT. THE
CITY OF LOS ANGELES NOW ONLY
GOT MONEY BACK FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT BUT ALSO FOR STATE
GOVERNMENT ACTUALLY FILLED OUT.
THESE FORMS FOR STATE GRANTS
ACTUALLY FILLED OUT- FORMS TO
GET. IT FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AND I THINK I DID A
PRETTY GOOD JOB WE NEVER HAD TO
BORROW MONEY. TO BE ABLE TO
DEAL WITH THIS NOW IT SEEMS.
LIKE A LOT OF MUNICIPALITIES.
EITHER NOT GETTING THEIR
MONEY'S BECAUSE PEOPLE ARE
TRAINED WITHIN THE
INFRASTRUCTURE OR THERE'S A
DELAY. OR THEY JUST MISS. BEING
ABLE TO APPLY FOR IT ALTOGETHER
BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE PEOPLE
THERE. THAT KNOW HOW TO GET
MONEY BACK FROM FEMA. AND SO I.
THE STATE USED TO BE PRETTY
GOOD AT ENSURING THAT WE HAD
PEOPLE IN EVERY MUNICIPALITY
THAT WAS TRAINED TO DO THAT I
THINK WE EVEN. THERE WAS EVEN A
LAW THAT MADE IT A REQUIREMENT
THAT WE HAD AT THIS
INFRASTRUCTURE AND- AND SO I'M
JUST KIND OF CURIOUS BECAUSE
I'M I'M I GET THE FEELING THAT
MAY BE BUDGET CUTS. THAT THAT'S
BEEN DECIMATED AND WE DON'T
HAVE THAT INFRASTRUCTURE
ANYMORE AND I COULD BE WRONG
AGAIN I HAVEN'T. I'VE BEEN IN
EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS
COORDINATOR SINCE NINETEEN
NINETY FOUR. WHICH IS PROBABLY
WHY WE HAVEN'T HAD ANY MAJOR
DISASTERS AND MIKE NINETEEN
NINETY FOUR BUT THAT'S A- I
JUST WANT TO KNOW WHAT WHAT THE
WHAT IS THAT INFRASTRUCTURE
STILL THERE DOESN'T EXIST WHAT
ARE WE DOING. THANK YOU SIR FOR
THAT EXCELLENT QUESTIONS AND-
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE IN.
OUR NEXT SO. YES I BELIEVE THAT
INFRASTRUCTURE IS STILL THERE-
WE- STILL ENCOURAGE LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS YOU CREATE AND
MAINTAIN THEIR EMERGENCY
OPERATION PLANS- WE HAVE THE
STATE LEVEL EMERGENCY PLANS
HERE AT YES- WE DO TRAINING
EXERCISES THROUGH OUR
CALIFORNIA SPECIALIZED TRAINING
INSTITUTE- IN AREAS RELATING TO
YOU. AFTER THIS MATERIAL. YEAH
AND CRIMINAL DOES- AND LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS OTHER STATE
AGENCIES HOW STRAINING
INSTITUTES AS WELL- I CANNOT
SPEAK TO YOU- ANY ARE.
CROSSCUTTING EFFECTS THAT MAY
HAVE OCCURRED AT THE LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS AND ANECDOTALLY
WE PART OF THEM AS AS I'M SURE
YOU HAVE THAT- MAKE A CALL FOR
THEM TO YOU AT TEN TRAINING
THEN CONDUCTING FOR THIS WHICH
ARE CAUGHT. WE IT HELLO YES AND
THAT THAT LOCAL- COMMITTEE
MAYBES MAYBE- WE CREATED THE
COMMUNITY PLANNING UNIT- WE'RE
DEVELOPING BEST PRACTICES FOR
EMERGENCY PLANNING THAT ****
OUT AND BE. AVAILABLE TO ALL
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS THIS YEAR
AND GREW VERY EIGHT PIECES OF
LEGISLATION IN THE LAST COUPLE
OF YEARS- WE'VE ENHANCED
LIGHTING AND WORK WITH THE
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS ON. TOPICS
FROM- HE- YOU KNOW BOTH THE
WARM IN THE ALERT. AND THAT AND
MANY OTHER AREAS. LEGISLATIVE
JUST LET YEAR REQUIREMENTS READ
YOU LOCAL FEET. A CERTAIN
AMOUNT EACH YEAR. OKAY AND
THERE OTHER THAT OBVIOUSLY ARE
COMING TO THE TOP OF MY MIND
BUT- I THINK IT DO READ YOU
THAT IS STILL IN. AND. THE
LOCAL. ARE OUR WORK IT AND THEY
ARE AT APPLYING FOR. AND IT
SEEMS THAT THE STATE MAYBE ARE
GAY. ACTUALLY MY BETTER AT IT-
AND THERE NOT ENOUGH FUNDING TO
VOTE FOR SO I'LL LEAVE THERE
AND IF YOU HAVE ANY FOR UP FOR
AFTER. TO SO MAYBE YOU CAN GIVE.
THIS COMMITTEE SOME SUGGEST. ON
HOW WE ALSO AN- THANK I DO
REMEMBER IN NINETY. THE TALK
ABOUT RICE LIKE ONE. NOW I
WOULD THAT PLAN. S. PRE. OF
THAT AND I REMEMBER ABOUT
DISEASE OR PANDEMIC. I COULD
SPELLED AND A FULL WE ARE NOW.
THIS IS A- PANDEMIC AND NOBODY.
BACK IN NINETEEN NINETY IF YOU
ARE QUOTE IF YOU TOLD SOMEONE
INTWENTY TWO. WE WOULD HAVE
WORLDWIDE. WERE WOULD BE
TALKING TO ONE ANOTHER WITH
MASS ON VACCINATIONS WORLDWIDE-
AND HOW AND TRY TO PLAN FOR HOW
TO DO THAT- PEOPLE PROBABLY
HAVE LAUGHED YOU OUT OF THE
ROOM BACK THEN AND IT IS A VERY
REAL THING AND SO I THINK IT'S
VERY IMPORTANT. THAT WE GET OUT
OF OUR OWN WAY AND PICK OUT OF
THE BOX ON HOW WE DO THOSE AND
WE NEED TO BOLSTER THAT
INFRASTRUCTURE SO THAT WE'RE
BETTER ADEPT AT A- THE DEALING
WITH THE LADIES UNKNOWNS.AND
THEN MY OTHER QUESTION IS JUST
ABOUT. D. G. I. S. SYSTEM NEXT
GENERATION I WANT ONE GRANT
PROGRAM- THAT YOU MAYBE YOU
GIVE US UPDATES ON HOW YOU
MOVING WITH THAT BECAUSE- LET'S
FACE IT GOVERNMENT IS NOT VERY
GOOD. AT INTERNET AND- COMPUTER
SYSTEMS AND- WE'VE BEEN. WE'VE
BEEN FAILURES ADDED AT EVERY
LEVEL IS NOT NOT JUST YOU IT'S
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL WHEN I WAS
IN THE CITY IT'S AT. FEDERAL
LEVEL AND WE EXPEND. OF
PROBABLY HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS ON VISA. UNDIES ON
THE SYSTEMS AND WE DON'T ALWAYS
GET WHAT WE SAID WE'RE PAYING
FOR AND SO IF YOU COULD. HELP
US HELP YOU BY LETTING US KNOW.
EARLY ON WHAT YOU NEED SO THAT
WE CAN GET THIS DONE. BUT MOST
IMPORTANT WE GET IT DONE ON
TIME HOPEFULLY UNDER BUDGET AND
YOU'RE NOT COMING BACK ASKING
FOR MORE MONEY. THANK YOU. YES
CHAIR AND OTHER MEMBERS HI THIS
IS- MITCH MEDIC IF IT'S WITHIN
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE WHICH
SERVICES AND- IN RESPONSE TO
YOUR QUESTION ON NEXT
GENERATION I WANT ONE ARC FROM
THE GRANTS THERE WERE FORTUNATE
ENOUGH TO HAVE BEEN THE
RECIPIENT OF THAT LARGE GRANT-
AND THAT WE BUILD INTO OUR
BUDGET FOR US AND THIS IS
ALLOWED US TO- ASSISTED ARE
PROGRAMMED AND HIRING THE
PERSONNEL WE NEED FOR THAT- THE
PROPOSAL PART OF YOU- TODAY IS-
THE CONTINUATION OF FIVE
LIMITED TERMS TO LIMITED TERM
PROBLEM. LIES TO SUPPORT OUR
GIS SIDE AND- CATTO'S WORK-
THAT'S WORKING VERY WELL-
POOREST THERE ARE MANY COUNTIES
THAT DON'T HAVE ANY GIS SUPPORT
AND STUDIES LIMITED TERM
PERSONNEL. HAVE HELPED. I TO
MOVE FORWARD. AND ACTS THAT.
REPORTS THERE THE- BUT THAT'S
PRETTY GRANT THOUGH ON WILL-
AND- TWENTY FOUR TO SO IT'S
KIND OF THE FINAL FIRST AND
THAT MONEY HOW WE WOULD START
NOT WANT TO READ THE FUNDS- TO
THE BETTER GO- NO AFTER THE-
STATE BAN OF COURSE AND NOT GET
THE HAVE BEEN OF HAVING A TO A-
SO I KIND OF INTEREST THAT THE
PC P. ITSELF BUT OVERALL- THE
MARIJUANA A PROGRAM FOR THE
MODERNIZATION OF NEXT
GENERATION I WANT ONE IT'S
GOING VERY WELL WE HAVE HAD
SOME DELAYS PARTICULARLY WITH
VENDORS- ON CERTAIN ITEMS SO
SUPPORT YOU CAN IMAGINE THAT
THE SUPPLY. CHAIN HAS BEEN
DISRUPTED- PROBLEM BUCKLE BIT
BUT OVERALL THE PROGRAM IS
WORKING ACTUALLY VERY WELL FOR
US AND THEN MOVING FORWARD AND
WE GO OUT AND ACTUALLY ACT I'D
BE HAPPY AT ANY POINT TO GIVE
YOU AN INDIVIDUAL PRETTY ON THE
PROGRAM AND OUR TEAM WALKING
THROUGH EXACTLY WHERE WE ARE-
WITH THAT THE ENTIRE ENDEAVOR.
THANK IN IT I JUST WANNA MAKE
SURE HOLD CONTRACT FEET TO FIRE.
AND THEN. YOU KNOW WE DON'T SU.
IT CONTRACTORS FOR MALFEASANCE
THEY CAN DELIVER JUST WALK
AWAY. FROM AN IT PROJECT AND
FOR WHATEVER REASON GOVERNMENT
DOESN'T GO AFTER THEM LIKE WE
DO WITH OTHER- CONTRACTOR SIZE
MAKE SURE BECAUSE IT IS
IMPORTANT. THE NEXT GENERATION
NINE ONE ONE IS IMPORTANT GRANT
SO LET'S MAKE SURE WE GET WHAT
WE PAY FOR OUR TAXPAYERS GET
WHAT THEY PAY FOR. THANK YOU.
UNDERSTOOD AND WE ARE DOING
THAT WERE HOLDING ABSOLUTE
ACCOUNTABLE AND ARE AND THEN.
YOU CAN REST ASSURED THAT WERE
PROTECTING EVERY OTHER DOLLAR
THAT SAID BEING PLACED A
DISTANT- I FEEL. LIKE I SAID
HAPPY TO WALK YOU THROUGH IN
DETAIL AND YOU KNOW. IT COULD
BE VERY UP. VERY HAPPY THE END-
BUT BURKE PROGRESS OR MAKE
APPROACH. THANK YOU. ANYWHERE
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS IN THIS
IS. OUR THANK YOU- I WOULD JUST
ASK THAT AS WE ARE- WORKING
WITH OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ON
LOCAL EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS
PLANS AND IT'S EXCITING TO HEAR
THAT LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE
PLANNING FOR THESE GRANTS- AND
IT SOUNDS LIKE THE PROGRAM
MIGHT BE GETTING OVERSUBSCRIBED
THAT WE TRACK TO MAKE SURE WE
HAVE EQUITY AND THAT THERE'S
NOT POCKETS OF CALIFORNIA THAT
ARE NOT APPLY AND ARE NOT
GETTING THEIR FAIR SHARE OF THE
PIE- WELL I WISH THAT THEY WERE
DOING IT ON THEIR OWN THE
SYSTEM THAT SOMEHOW SOMETIMES
STACKED AGAINST SOMEBODY'S
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND THEY'RE
NOT PREPARED ABLE TO DO IT WHEN
YOU HAVE A LOT OF. LOCAL
GOVERNMENT WITH THE GENERAL
BUDGET FUND OF NINE MILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR THEY DON'T
ALWAYS HAVE STAFF ON BOARD WHO
ARE PREPARED TO GO AFTER THESE
DOLLARS BUT THOSE ARE THE
COMMUNITIES THAT PROBABLY OUR
MOST VULNERABLE AND EAT THE
MOST PLANNING A LONG HAN SO I
WOULD JUST ASK THAT AS WE ARE
TRACKING THE EXPENDITURE OF
THOSE DOLLARS THAT WE ARE
LOOKING AT REAL LIFE DATA TO
SEE IF THEY'RE ANY DONALD
HOLDER THAT LIKE TO SAY WHERE.
WE NEED TO MAYBE PAY A LITTLE
EXTRA ATTENTION AHEAD OF TIME.
THANK YOU- I WILL MOVE ON TO
ISSUE NUMBER THREE WHICH IS
ABOUT MOLD ACTION SITES- WE
HAVE SEEN A CAL YES ACROSS THE
STATE WORKING IN COLLABORATION
WITH PEOPLE ON MOBILE VEXING
SITES AND SO I WOULD LIKE TO
HEAR A LITTLE BIT MORE FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH THIS
COLLABORATIONS GOING THEN
YOU'RE A ROLE- AND THESE IN
BRINGING THESE MOLD ACTION
SITES. TO COMMUNITIES. THANK
YOU. YEAH AND MEMBERS LAURIE
NATURE AGAIN. HELLO YEAH
FUNDING REQUIRED AND PREVENTION.
WE BEGAN ON FIFTEENTH. IN MY
HELLO YES I THINK THAT YOU BACK
CLINIC ONE IT OKAY OAKLAND
COLISEUM THE RENT WHAT IT EIGHT
ONE ANGELES HE STILL. HE'S ARE
PART OF WITH THE BY NEED
MINUTES AND THE MATH WITH THE
INTENT OF IT THAT INDIVIDUALS
AND OTHERS ARE COMMUNITIES
RECEIVE EVERY OPPORTUNITY. TO
RECEIVE IT BACK TO ME I WANT.
THE VACCINE ALLOCATION WE RISK
FOR THESE. YOU THE THAT WHICH
THEY SAY IS ALREADY RECEIVING
LIKE DOESN'T IMPACT BACK.
SUPPLY AT THE OR PROVIDER SURE
ALREADY TO THAT THE FACT. IT
CHARLIE THING BECAUSE THEIR
PRODUCT. UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES AND BEEN HARDEST
BACK FOR THE NIGHT. WE HAVE A
HAVE TO BE AT THE TO BACK MAYBE
SIX THOUSAND AND FIVE HUNDRED
PEOPLE PER DAY. AND THAT'S
INCLUDE OUR MOBILE THAT
PROVIDED THIS AROUND
COMMUNITIES THE FACT NAY PEOPLE
TO THEY LIVE IN WORK. THERE ARE
AT SCHOOL. TWO TWO HUNDRED IT'S
SIX YEAH WORKING AT THE AT-
YEAH RIGHT. THAT IT'S COMPRISED
OF ONE THREE HUNDRED THREE. HOW
LA. AT EIGHT HUNDRED EIGHTY AT
OPEN. AND THEN ANOTHER FORTY
FIVE TO FIFTY HURT EACH OF THE
MOBILE CLINIC AND WE HAVE SIX
OF THEM NOW. THIS IS TRULY AND
ALL OF STATE AND FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT OPERATION WE HAVE
LET ME JUST READ OFF SOME OF
THE STATE AGENCIES THAT ARE
INVOLVED WITH THAT IN THIS
CAMPAIGN. HELLO YES. CALIFORNIA
MILITARY DEPARTMENT VALLEY PA
CALTRANS. WILDLIFE SOUTHWIRE
BERMAN REHABILITATION SALARY
FRANCHISE TAX BOARD DEPARTMENT
OF TECHNOLOGY HELP HURT
CONSUMER AFFAIRS AND
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION
DESTINY WITH YOU ALL THE
GOVERNMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH I
WOULDN'T WANT TO FORGET THEM.
AND MEN ARE FEDERAL AGENCY
PARTNERS HAVE BEEN ENOUGH
DEPARTMENT OF DEFENSE US FOREST
SERVICE US HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES. BOTH FIRED AND IT
DIGITALLY DISASTER MEDICAL
SYSTEM AND AMERICORPS MEMBERS
HAVE BEEN CALL THAT YOU STAFF
THE LOCATION. I TRULY TRULY
HAVE PROPERLY HERE. I
APPOINTMENTS FOR THESE CLINICS
ARE SCHEDULED MY FOR THAT CA
GOV OR THE AT THIS PRESS
PROGRAM. NINETEEN I THE MATH
THANK THEY'RE BOTH RIGHT LANE
AND WALK UP BUT TEACHING SPEAKS
TRANSPORT. OUR OUR OF OPERATION
AT THE MAX RIGHT OUR NINETY TO
SEVEN PM SEVEN DAYS WEEK. AND
BY THE MOBILE THAT OUT INTO THE
THAT. YEAH ARE THE HOURS OF
ABOUT AND I'M NOT OR TEN AM. TO
ABOUT OR FOUR PM. THERE'S NO.
TO THOSE ONE TO WITH BACK FROM
ANY OF THESE CLINICS. I THINK
WE HAD FACT NEED TWO HUNDRED
FIFTH. SEVEN THOUSAND SEVEN
HUNDRED SIXTY THREE PEOPLE OF
ALL AND THE OTHER PERSON
DOESN'T AT ALL OF OUR THANK.
THANK YOU. TWO HUNDRED THIRTY
FIVE THOUSAND EIGHT HUNDRED
TWENTY FIVE PEOPLE AT OUR MATH
SITE OPEN COLISEUM EMPOWER FEET
AWAY. AND ANOTHER. ONE THOUSAND
NINE HUNDRED THIRTY EIGHT
PEOPLE. AT OUR MOBILE UNIT.
TODAY ACTUALLY BEGIN THEIR
FIRST DAY OF THE SECOND
NOTICES- ADMINISTRATION AT THE
MATH RIGHT AND ON THURSDAY WILL
BEGIN SECOND BENEFIT IS THAT
MOST OF OUR MOBILE CLINIC. LET
ME JUST BASICALLY TALK ABOUT
OUR MOBILE. WE GET WITH YOU
MOBILE UNITS EACH SITE. DOING
L. A. K. YOU'RE AN ALUM. BUT
WE'VE NOW EXPAND TO MILES UNIT
EACH IN ONE ANGELES AND I YOU
CAN. WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH
THE WHOLE OF COMMUNITY BASED
FOR AND- ALAMEDA PUBLIC HEALTH
AND LOS ANGELES HEALTH IS
SCHEDULED HOLD IN THE- WITH THE
GREATEST NEED. AND THAT YOU
NEED IN THE LOWER COURT AND H.
YEAH I AND WITH THE LAW BACK.
RATE IT IS. THE MOBILE UNITS
EVERY OR TWO BUT A PART OF FIVE
OF ART MEDIA AND CO HEALTH. WE
REALLY MOBILE AT THIS
COMMUNITIES THAT BROOKLINE DAYS.
MONEY FRIDAY. JERKER OTHER CASE
THAT. BASED WORKING SATURDAY
SUNDAY. WORKING VERY WELL AND
IT'S BEEN WELL BY THE- IT. HAS
A HOST CBO THAT WERE WITH
SEEKING UNDER THE- DID YOU
OUTRAGE IN THE COMMUNITY. WE
PROVIDE YOU WITH A LIST OF
SITES WHERE WE HAVE SINCE THE
BEGINNING OF FEBRUARY BUT I
WOULD JUST YOU A LITTLE OF
WHERE WE ARE TODAY. I IN.
ALAMEDA COUNTY. TODAY WORKING
WITH THE FOLLOW CD LAST SUNDAY
GOT NOT MISSIONARY BACK CHURCH
AND TRY TO FIND A- AND IN LAST.
WE BUT- AS PROBABLY WHAT THE
ANALYTICAL GETS ARE ARMY AND
WHERE IT FELT ARE. BURGER ALSO
ACTIVE OWNED CAR AND WE'RE
WE'RE WITH CHARLES ARE YOU.
THIS IS GIVING YOU GOOD IDEA I
YEAH OUR OPERATIONS THEN NOW.
SCALE AND WERE WERE UP- WE BE
SITES IN AND I SUFFERER FOR
EIGHT WEEKS OR MORE. AND I'M
HAPPY ANSWER QUESTIONS THAT THE
MEETING A TOP OF THE HELLO YES
EMAIL BACK. BURKE. THANK YOU I
APPRECIATE IT CAN YOU EXPLAIN
TO ME THE ROLE OF THE K. OF
THERE'S ANY ROLE AND SELECTING
WHERE THE SITES PIMA A CALLOW
YOUTH TEAM AFFECTS ARE GOING TO
BE AT. ABSOLUTELY SO WE HAVE-
WE HAVE TWICE WEEKLY CALLS WITH
ALAMEDA COUNTY PUBLIC HEALTH
AND LIFESPAN FOR PUBLIC HEALTH.
AND AT THOSE TIMES WE DISCUSS-
WHERE DOES THAT THE BEST SITES
WOULD BE FOR THE FOLLOWING
WEEK. AND DOES THAT COUNTIES
HAVE BEEN PROVIDING. REALLY
GREAT SUGGESTIONS WE SENSE
RIGHT I THANK MY TEAM OUT TO
LOOK AT THOSE VARIOUS SITES TO
SEE WHICH WOULD BE THE- BEST
FOR THE OPERATION. AND THEN THE
AND THEN WE CHOOSE- WHICH OF
THOSE SITE INTO FOR THE
FOLLOWING WEEK SO IT'S BEEN
VERY CALL. THEN IT. CAN I GUESS
AND MY SECOND QUESTION IS- YOU
ARE PLANNING A WEEK AHEAD. IS
THERE ANY WAY THAT WE CAN PLAN
LONGER THAN A WEEK AHEAD SINCE
WE KNOW THAT VACCINATIONS.
PRESIDENTE TAKE LONGER GETTING
EQUITY IS GOING TO TAKE LONGER-
IT'S HARD ON THE GROUND. TO DO
THE WORK AHEAD OF TIME WHEN
WORST WE HAVE A FORTY EIGHT OUT
BY THE TIME IT GETS TO THE
COMMUNITY GROUPS THAT ARE
HELPING WE HAVE BETWEEN TWENTY
FOUR TO FORTY EIGHT HOURS TO
SIGN UP. A HUNDRED TO FIVE
HUNDRED PEOPLE AT THE SITE. I
AND I KNOW WHEN AN EMERGENCY SO
I KNOW THAT PLANNING ISN'T
ALWAYS POSSIBLE BUT YOU KNOW
THE VACCINE PRICES GONNA TAKE A
LITTLE WHILE AT THE RATE WE'RE
GOING IS THERE ANY WAY TO PRESS
OUR ABILITY FIFTH PLAN. MORE
THAN A WEEK AHEAD OF TIME. I SO
GREAT QUESTION AND ONE THAT WE
HAVE BEEN WORKING ON AND HERE
IS WHERE WE STAND TODAY. WE
HAVE. TO WELL POOR TOO MANY
FLOW EACH COUNTY. OF OUR MOBILE
UNITS ARE GOING INTO SECOND
THOSE IS SO WE ACTUALLY KNOW
EXACTLY WHERE THEY'RE GOING TO
BE FOR THE NEXT THREE WEEKS-
BECAUSE- THEY HAVE TO GO BACK
TO THE SITE WHERE THEY- DID THE
FIRST DOSE. ADMINISTRATION SO
FOR THEM WHERE WE'RE THREE IN
ADVANCE NOW FOR THE THIRD
MOBILE SITE THAT CAME ON JUST
THIS LAST WEEK. WHERE ABOUT TWO
WEEKS OUT IN OUR SCHEDULING SO-
WE HAVE HEARD AS YOU HAVE AT
THAT OUR- HEROES ON THE GROUND
NEED A LITTLE BIT MORE LEAD
TIME TO DO THE OUTREACH SO. WE
ARE ABOUT TWO WEEKS OUT IN THE
SCHEDULING FOR THOSE. AND THEN
IN THE LIST OF MANY STATE
AGENCIES THAT YOU'RE WORKING
WITH AND I DO APPRECIATE ALL OF
OUR STATE EMPLOYEES BOTH AT A
CALLAWAY YES AND THE MANY
AGENCIES. WHO ARE STEPPING UP
AND LIKE THE GOVERNOR SAYS TO
ME THE MOMENT OUT THERE BUT IN
IN THAT I DIDN'T HEAR ANY
COLLABORATION WITH THE
LEGISLATURE. ARE INFORMATION
SHARING WITH THE INFORMATION
WITH THE LEGISLATURE IS THAT.
AN ACCIDENT IS THAT ON PURPOSE
OR KIND OF WHAT'S GOING ON
THERE- I DIDN'T. I DIDN'T
MENTION THAT COLLABORATION IS
GOING ON WITH THE- THE
LEGISLATURE BECAUSE IT'S NOT
OPERATIONAL IN NATURE BUT THERE
IS A LOT OF INFORMATION SHARING
THAT IT'S GOING ON- WE HAVE.
TWICE WEEKLY MEETING- WITH THE
LEGISLATURE WHICH WE REPORT OUT
ON ALL THE-VACCINE OPERATIONS
AND TAKE ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS- MORE ACTION. AND THEN
I BELIEVE THERE'S A OF
LEGISLATIVE MAKING GRIFFITH ALL
FOR AND MEETING REGULARLY AND
WE'RE PROVIDING. TO THEM ON A
REGULAR. WITH ALL ALL GET TO
POINT OF THESE I EIGHT REP.
HALF OF SOUTH L. A. COUNTY SURE
THAT WITH THE SPEAKER. AND IF
YOU LOOK AT THE VACCINATION
RATES WE ARE IN THE BOTTOM OF
WE HAVE ABOUT ONE IN TWENTY
PEOPLE WHO ARE VACCINATED AT
THE LAST DATA POINTS BUT OUR
INFECTION RATES ARE THAT'S
RIGHT OUR HOUSE BOTH A SINCE
THE RATES ARE REALLY. HIGH I
KEEP REFERRING TO MY- MY
RECEIPTS. FOR THE DATA OUT
THERE WE LOOK AT COMMUNITIES
LIKE MINE. AND THE COMMUNITY
HAS BEEN ORGANIZING ON THE
GROUND WITH THE PHILIP
COLLABORATIVE AND OF NOW THE
MOBILE SITE THAT WE HAVE- IN
SOUTH GATE WELL WE HAVE LOTS OF
DIFFERENT PIECES TALKING WE
WEREN'T ALL TALKING TO EACH
OTHER- PEOPLE WERE GETTING
BLOWN UP IN DIFFERENT
CAPACITIES- AND- A LOT OF
FRUSTRATION ON THE GROUND A LOT
OF MISINFORMATION. CLEANING FOR
MYSELF I HAD TO SPEND MULTIPLE
DAYS NOT JUST MY STAFF OF
MYSELF MAKING PHONE CALLS TO
SAY WHAT'S GOING ON HERE AND
GETTING YELLED AT BY PEOPLE
WHEN I WOULD CALL TO ASK HIM
WHAT'S GOING ON BECAUSE THEY
WERE SO FRUSTRATED- AND IN THIS
MOMENT OUT THERE AND SO. I
WOULD SAY FOR MYSELF AND MY
COLLEAGUES WE ARE HERE TO BE OF
SERVICE IN BE OF HELP AND
SUPPLEMENT THE EFFORTS THAT YOU
ARE DOING- BOTH THROUGH THE
STATE AND IN COLLABORATION WITH
THE WITH P. MINE WITH THE
COUNTY- BUT WE DO NEED TO
IMPROVE THAT COMMUNICATIO. A
LITTLE BIT MORE I AM VERY
APPRECIATIVE FOR THE SITE THAT
IS IN SOUTH GATE THERE ARE
ABOUT A DOZEN CITIES IN
SOUTHEAST L. A. COUNTY AND
THEY'VE DECIDED TO WORK
TOGETHER TO RACE TO THE END.
AND APPRECIATE OVER WHEREVER
THE SITE'S SLAMMED IN THEIR
COMMUNITY BUT WE HAVE NOW THIS
COVER THAT WITHOUT THAT
ANTICIPATION AHEAD OF TIME IT'S
HARD TO PLAN AHEAD AS WE'RE
TRYING TO DO EDUCATION. TRYING
TO GET THROUGH THE INSIDE OF
THE COMMUNITY MEMBERS HAVE THE
DISTRUST- AND THE AND IF YOU'RE
AND SO THERE'S A LOT OF WORK
THAT EEDS TO GO INTO
CONVINCING SOMEONE TO HAVE A TO
GET A VACCINE. AND THE
COMMUNITY I SPENT SUNDAY ALL OF
THEM THE OTHER DAY. DRIVING
AROUND THIS WEEKEND LOOKING FOR
VENDORS. WHO ARE VERY- AND
SHOULD BE BACK FROM. AND OTHER
THEM HAD EVER GOT BACK FROM THE
AND WE'RE- I THINK BILLION
NUMBER THE SAME UP- AND ARE
GOING TO BE SHOWING UP. ON
TUESDAY IN IN SOUTH GATE- BUT I
WOULD JUST WHEREVER POSSIBLE AS
WE ARE REFINING THIS PROCESS.
IN ALL FAIRNESS WE ARE ONLY A
MONTH INTO THIS. AND SO I
REALIZED. THAT WILLIAM WENT
INTO THIS BUT WE ARE YEAR INTO
THE PANDEMIC WHEN YOU'RE A
VACCINE WAS COMING. ON AND SO
AS QUICKLY AS WE CAN WE NEED TO
IMPROVE THIS PROCESS. SO THAT
WE CAN BACK TO MEET AS MANY
PEOPLE IN THESE COMMUNITIES
THAT ARE HIGHLY AFFECTED EVER
REALLY WANNA BE NONE THE CURVE
AND BE EQUITABLE AND SO. I JUST
YOU KNOW WHEREVER YOU CAN GO
BEYOND- BEYOND THE GROUP THAT
YOU HAVE ALREADY I WAS IN THE
EGISLATURE TO TALK TO THE
MEMBERS WHO ARE REPRESENTING
THESE HIGHLY IMPACTED
COMMUNITIES- AND FORTUNATELY.
WITH EVERYTHING IS INTERESTING
THAT WE'RE GETTING THAT
INFORMATION EITHER AND WHAT'S
GOING ON UNTIL WE HAVING TO
PIECE IT TOGETHER SO. WOULD
APPRECIATE THAT INFORMATION I
HOPE AT SOME POINT WERE ABLE TO
GET. PAST THIS DIANNE
CALOPHYLLACEAE IT INTO MORE
THESE MOBILE CLINICS IN THE
COMMUNITY- IN SOUTH GATE THERE
WERE A LOT OF COMMITTEE MEMBERS
THAT HAVE BEEN SHOWING UP.
WANTING TO GET VACCINATED OR
NOT SIGNED UP AND WE'RE TAKING
A MOMENT TO SIGN UP FOR A
FUTURE. OF APPOINTMENT OF FOR A
FUTURE DATE. BUT IT MAKES A BIG
DIFFERENCE WHEN IT'S IN YOUR
BACKYARD AND A TRUSTED SOURCE
LIKE YOU SAID A CHURCH OR A
PARK. AND SO WHAT WE NEED TO
PLAN AHEAD IT'S HARD TO HAVE
THE MOVING AROUND- IT'S HELPFUL
IF THE MOVES BEYOND THE CITY
FLVS IS TRYING TO MAKE ITS WAY
THROUGH THIS REGION THAT'S BEEN
SO. HIGHLY IMPACTED IN FRONT OF
ESTIMATED. ALONG THE WAY AND SO.
WE ARE HERE TO BE OF SERVICE TO
BE PARTNERS- I DO APPRECIATE
THE EFFORTS AND- I WILL SAY
JUST IN THE LAST FIVE DAYS A
SEEN. CALLAWAY IS WORKING LONG
HOURS WITH US. IF THEY BY PHONE
FOR THANK YOU FOR THAT. AND
IMPROVING THEIR OPERATIONS
REGULARLY AND TRYING TO TAKE
ADVICE FROM THE WILL. OF GROUPS-ON THE GROUND. SO I DO KNOW
YOUR ADJUSTING ALONG THE WAY
BUT WE HAVE A WAY TO GO. THEY
WERE REALLY GOING TO MEET THE
EQUITY GOALS THAT WE HAVE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. COMMENTS
CHAIR WELL NOTED AND I DO
APPRECIATE THEM. AND I DID
FORGET TO MENTION THAT- SEVERAL
OF THE SITE- SELECTED HAVE BEEN
AN ATHLETE- THAT REQUESTED THAT
THE RECOMMENDATION. OF LOCAL
AND- STATE. LEGISLATIVE AND-
ELECTED OFFICIALS. SUCH AS
YOURSELF SO. I WILL DEFINITELY
REACH OUT AND- TRY TO. TO
PARTNER MORE WE UNDERSTAND THAT
YOU ARE THE TRUSTED VOICE. IN
YOUR COMMUNITY. AND YOU HAVE A
OF REACH WELL BEYOND. HOURS
INTO THE COMMUNITIES. THAT
MEANS THAT ARE SO DESPERATELY
TO BE VACCINATED SO- WE WILL-
WE WILL REACH OUT. AND MARK.
YOU ARE ELECTED OFFICIALS. YOU
WANT. TO MAKE SURE THAT WE GET
THIS STUFF DONE AND DONE RIGHT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ANY
QUESTIONS FROM MY COLLEAGUES.
OKAY THEN WE'RE GONNA GO AHEAD
AND CLOSE OF THIS PANEL I DO
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME AND YOUR
INFORMATION I LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU ON THIS ISSUE
WE'RE GOING TO GO AHEAD AND
MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER FOUR.
WE'RE GONNA BE TALKING TO BE
SEC ON VARIOUS BUDGET PROPOSALS.
WE WILL GO AHEAD AND LET THE
PANELISTS BEGAN AND THEY CAN GO
IN THE ORDER. LISTED IN THE
AGENDA. HE GOOD AFTERNOON
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I'M
KATIE HOWARD THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE BOARD OF STATE
AND COMMUNITY CORRECTIONS CAN
YOU HEAR ME OK. YES RIGHT THANK
YOU- AND YOU'D LIKE ME TO JUST
JUMP RIGHT INTO THE TITLE TO
ITEM CORRECT. CORRECT OKAY
THANK YOU I'M AS IS DESCRIBED
IN THE AGENDA THIS IS- A
PROPOSAL TO INCREASE THE BOARDS
ARE SPENDING AUTHORITY FOR A
GRANT THAT IS ADMINISTERED
UNDER TITLE TWO WHICH IS A
FEDERAL LAW HAVING TO DO WITH
JUVENILE JUSTICE AND
DELINQUENCY PREVENTION- AND
THIS. PROPOSAL DOES NOT AFFECT
THE GENERAL FUND THESE WOULD
BE- THIS WOULD BE A CHANGE THAT
WOULD ALLOW THE BOARD TO HAVE
ACCESS TO MORE FEDERAL DOLLARS
FOR AN IMPORTANT PROJECT THAT
OUR STATE ADVISORY COMMITTEE ON
JUVENILE JUSTICE AND
DELINQUENCY PREVENTION HAS
PLANNED- AND THAT IS A PROPOSAL
TO HAVE A CONSULTANT DO SOME
WORK CONNECTED WITH. REDUCING
RACIAL AND ETHNIC DISPARITIES
IN COUNTY JUVENILE JUSTICE
SYSTEMS- A LITTLE BIT MORE
DETAIL IS LAID OUT IN THE
AGENDA AND I'M VERY HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE BUT THIS IS A REALLY
SIMPLE- PROPOSAL JUST TO ALLOW
US TO GET ACCESS TO THOSE
DOLLARS. ANY COMMENTS FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. I MEAN
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WE HAVE
NO COMMENT ON THIS PROPOSAL AT
THIS TIME. L. A. L. AT. YOU
KNOW WHAT THE L. A. OKAY WE
DIDN'T RAISE ANY CONCERNS ON
THIS PROPOSAL. FOR ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS TO THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. NO ONE
SECOND.
TO BUDGET. I APOLOGIZE
THERE'S TWO BUDGET PROPOSAL
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WILL YOU
BE SPEAKING ON THE FIRST ONE.
OR THE SECOND ONE I ASK.
QUESTION WITH REGARDING THE
FIRST PROPOSAL- GOOD AFTERNOON
CHARACENE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS JUSTIN
EVAN AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND I WILL PROVIDE A
BRIEF OVERVIEW. OF THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL TO
AMEND THE SB SIX SEVEN EIGHT
FORMULA. AT THE LEGISLATURE
DESIGNED SB SIX SEVEN EIGHT
PROGRAM THE TWO PURPOSES ONE
CAN ONLY BE STATE PRISON
OVERCROWDING. TO STATE STATE
GENERAL FUND MONEY. I THESE ARE
ACCOMPLISHED WITHOUT
COMPROMISING PUBLIC SAFETY BY
ENCOURAGING COUNTY PROBATION
DEPARTMENT USED EVIDENCE BASED
SUPERVISION PRACTICES. TO
REDUCE THE NUMBER OF
INDIVIDUALS ON FELONY
SUPERVISION OR SENT TO STATE
PRISONS. SB SIX SEVENTY GRANT
FORMULA INCENTIVIZE COUNTIES
ACCOMPLISH THIS GOAL. LAST YEAR
HE PROVIDED A HUNDRED AND
TWELVE POINT FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS TO COUNTY FOR ITS
PURPOSE. THE ADMINISTRATION
PROPOSES TO MODIFY THE
STATUTORY FORMULA FOR SB SIX
SEVENTY EIGHT I MERELY DUE TO
THE COMPLETE NINETEEN PANDEMIC
AND ITS IMPACTS TO THE NUMBER
OF INDIVIDUALS COMMITTED TO
STATE PRISONS IN TWENTY TWENTY.
I THIS WOULD AMEND THE FORMULA
PROVIDE A SET AMOUNT OF A
HUNDRED TWENTY TWO POINT EIGHT
MILLION GENERAL FUND OR ABOUT
TEN POINT THREE MILLION
INCREASE OVER THE PRIOR YEAR
FOR TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO. I
THIS MONTH PROVIDES THE HIGHEST
SB SIX SEVENTY EIGHT EACH
COUNTY OVER THE PAST THREE
YEARS. I WAS GONNA GET A LITTLE
TECHNICAL HERE THANK COLLEGE
EYES BUT THE FUNDS ARE
PREDICATED ON THREE COMPONENTS
THE FIRST EXACT COUNT
TO PRISON READS FOR THE
REPLICATION RATE WHICH IS
DETERMINED BY HOW MANY
INDIVIDUALS ON FELONY
SUPERVISION. ARE SENT OUT OF
THE COUNTY SEVENTY TWO
PROVISION POPULATION. OF A
SECOND COMPARE COMPONENT IS A
COMPARISON OF EACH COUNTIES
RETURNED TO PRISON RATE AND
IT'S RATE IN THE PREVIOUS YEAR.
AT THIS IS PRIMARILY THE
INCENTIVE COMPONENT AND IT'S
COMPARING YEAR TO YEAR DATA
PROVIDED ADDITIONAL FUNDS TO
COUNTIES THE SEND YOU WERE
INDIVIDUALS TO PRISON FROM
FANTASY PREVENTION. AND THEY
DIDN'T PREVIOUS YEAR SO THEY'RE
DEMONSTRATING A SUCCESS AND THE
INCENTIVIZE BACK THROUGH THIS
COMPOUND. I THE THIRD COMPONENT
PROVIDES A MINIMUM OF TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS ALL
COUNTIES THAT REPORT
PROVISIONING REVOCATION DATA AS
REQUIRED BY THE. LAW A CODE
NINETEEN HIS SIGNIFICANT HIM.
BY THE FIRST TO COMPLY THAT THE-
FOR. IF YOU CAMPUS. AND THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. AT THE STATE
BY RECORD REQUEST REPLY SIX PER.
IN ABOUT OUT SEVENTY PROBATION
REVOCATION DIFFERENT. AND THAT
RESULTED IN THE HUNDRED TWELVE
POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLAR
PAYMENT. A ON DATA THAT WE
RECEIVE FOR THIS SIX MONTHS OF.
TWO ONLY ABOUT TWENTY FIVE
HUNDRED. FOR A GROUP OF THE
PRISON AND THE TRAIN SHOWS
DOWNWARD. I'M ASKING YOU ONE ON.
WE GETTING PAID ONLY FOUR FIVE.
INDIVIDUAL WOULD BE.
IMPRISONING YEAR TWENTY. WHICH
WOULD RESULT IN OF ABOUT A
EIGHTY SIX NO DOLLARS- UNDER
THE- FORMULA. BECAUSE OF THAT
WE BELIEVE OFTEN IN AND BASED
THE STORY TREND IS REASONABLE.
YOU THE IMPACT THAT THAT. ON
PRISON. AND CONNECT. ARE
FINALLY I WANT TO NOTE THIS. IS
AN TO BE A TEMPORARY. I THERE
ARE OTHER. JUSTICE FOR MEASURES
SUCH AS EIGHTY NINETEEN FIFTY.
INTRODUCED INTEGRATION OF MOST
PROBATION TERMS WHICH ALSO WILL
IMPACT THE EXISTING FORMULA.
ARE THESE VARIOUS FACTORS ARE
GOING TO REQUIRE FUTURE
MODIFICATION OF THE EXISTING
FORMULA. MAINTAIN THE GOAL SB
SIX SEVENTY AND INCENTIVIZING
THE WORK OF COUNTY PROBATION
DEPARTMENT'S. IN MINIMIZING
CALIFORNIA'S PRISON POPULATION
AND MAINTAINING PUBLIC SAFETY.
I WOULD. MORE THAN HAPPY. TO
TAKE ANY NUMBER QUESTIONS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU FOR THAT. ON THE
L. A. O. HAVE ANYTHING TO ADD
TO THAT. THANK YOU R. O. THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
IN ADDITION TO THE INPUT BOX
FROM THE PANDEMIC ON THE
REPLICATION RATE IN THE
SUPERVISION NO WAY OUT.
FINANCES ALSO NOTE THAT SOME
RECENT POLICY CHANGES WILL ALSO
LIKELY. SB SIX SEVEN EIGHT
AWARDS. FIRST AS PART OF THE
COMPANY TEAM TO CAN START AT
LEAST THE PEOPLE FROM PRESENTED
SOME OF THOSE GOING ON. TO AS
YOU PROVISION BY CONCORD OF. AT
INDIVIDUALS CAN TOWARDS THAT SB
SIX SEVEN EIGHT FOUR OF THE
BEST IN WHAT THAT- SILVA FOUGHT
THROUGH. AND THESE PEOPLE THIS
HOW SUPPORT. OF THE POPULATIONS
OF THIS INCREASED BY COULD
HAPPEN IN ON THE- RATE GOING-
AND TELL THE POPULATION RETURNS
ALL OF. BECAUSE IT'S A
PROVISION IN THE SECOND IMPACT
IS A NINETY FIFTY WHICH. WE DO
STILL HAVE THE TIME PEOPLE HER.
THEN BECAUSE PEOPLE BECOME LESS
TO BE SET TO PRISON OVER. THIS
IN. THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE BUT
LESS BE SENT TO PRESIDENT
EXPLAINING PEOPLE GOVERNMENT
RECOGNITION TO PRISON. AND
THAT'S WHAT ALSO INCREASE THE
LACK WEEK BECAUSE THE OFFICE
SOMEONE WHO'S GONE SUPER AND
FAILING GOING OR THAT COULD
HAPPEN IF THE CASE IS WHAT
FORMULA. THESE IMPACT ON
COMPLETELY TO CONTROLLED COUNTY
BOARD OF OUR- AND SO WE DO
THINK IN A TO SIX ON EIGHT IS A
PROGRAM AND THEN OUT. WE DO
HAVE CONCERNS THAT THEY JUST
COULD UNDERMINE INTENT AS THE
SEVEN EIGHT IF IT IS MADE FOR
PRIME. AN ASTRONAUT OUT OF.
WOULD BE ON. SO WE ARE TO PUT
THE HUNDRED ONE TIME BASIS AND
THEN CORRECT THAT MISSED. RIGHT
ALONG TERM. SB SIX EIGHT. IS
THAT CORRECT THE LAST DOT BUT
LISTS DIRECT DEPARTMENT I KNOW.
TO PROVIDE LITTLE FROM
PROTECTING US THE SIX SEVEN
EIGHT FIVE YEAH TEND TWENTY.
NINETY ONE A QUICK. THE ARE AT
NOT THAT DEALING WITH YOUR
COMMA UP FORMULA OR ABOUT THE-
FOR MAKING THOSE ARE BUT-
ALLOCATIONS. SB SIX SEVEN. FIVE
WE CAN TWENTY TWENTY. WELL WHAT
WE ARE ONE IN OUR- IS THAT THEY
UP WITH A PLAN. HOW LONG. SOME
OF INTO STRUCTURE THAT IS PART
OF SB SIX. CURRENTLY GETS WHICH
GOING. FOR AT THE MOMENT WE
DON'T HAVE A PLAN FOR HOW LONG
IT WOULD LAST- WE DO
APPRECIATE. YOUR TIME. WE
CAN'T. REACH CHANGES TO THE
FARMING ARE NECESSARY BUT IT'S
HARD TO TELL GIVEN THE CHANGES.
SPECIFICALLY IS ALREADY GOING
INTO TWENTY TWENTY ONE TO ONE
ACTIONABLE DATA WOULD BE
AVAILABLE TO DEVELOP A PLAN FOR
NEXT YEAR BUT IN THE FUTURE WE
ARE. OPEN TO. DRESSING THAT
FORMULA. EXOTERIC CHANGES. I
MEAN LET ME GO ON THE RECORD
THAT THIS COMMITTEE IS MILLION.
WITH GIVING THESE. OPEN ENDED
ALLOCATIONS OR NOT HAVING A
PLAN. LONG TERM AND CREATING A
PRECEDENT- IN THIS SITUATION.
AND SO. WHILE WE DO HAVE A
PANDEMIC WE ARE FORCED TO MULTI
TASK ON A REGULAR BASIS OUR
TAXPAYERS. EXPECT THAT OF US
AND SO I DOHOPE. THAT THE NEXT
TIME WE MEET OUR AND IN THE
FUTURE YOU'RE ABLE TO PROVIDE
US WITH. SOME IDEA OF HOW LONG
THIS WOULD GO ON FOR. AND FROM.
SOME ESTIMATION. ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ON THIS ITEM. OKAY
THANK YOU FOR THAT. AND THEN IN
THAT CASE WE'RE GOING TO GO
AHEAD AND MOVE ON TO THE LAST-
ISSUE ITEM NUMBER FIVE. WHERE
AGAIN THE SEC IS GONNA GIVE US
A REVIEW OF THE STATE STANDARDS
AND INSPECTIONS FOR LOCAL
DETENTION FACILITIES. AT WILL
BEGIN WITH AN OVERVIEW FROM THE
L. A. ON THE REPORT AND THEN
OTHER PANELISTS WILL SPEAK IN
THE ORDER LISTED IN THE AGENDA.
AS BEGAN. OKAY I KNOW NEIL AT
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE. I'VE BEEN ASKED TO
PROVIDE A BRIEF OVERVIEW OF OUR
RECENT REPORT FINDING IT DC'S
PROGRAM FOR SETTING STANDARDS
FOR INSPECTING LOCAL DETENTION
FACILITIES SUCH AS JAILS AND
JUVENILE HALLS- I'LL BE
SPEAKING FROM A HANDOUT WHICH
I'VE MEMBERS SHOULD I BELIEVE
HI HAVE- AND FOR THOSE WHO ARE.
FOLLOWING ALONG REMOTELY YOU
CAN ACCESS IT VIA THE SENATE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE UNDER THE-
THE AGENDAS TAB OR FROM OUR
WEBSITE AT LEóN DOT CA DOT.
PUBLICATIONS THANK HANDOUT
DESCRIBES IN BACKGROUND ON BST
THIS IS YOUR FOR REFERENCE
INTEREST OF TIME I AM GOING TO
MOVE ON TO PAGE TWO I'M WHICH
PROVIDES A BRIEF OVERVIEW OF
THE LOCAL DETENTION FACILITIES
STANDARDS AND INSPECTIONS
PROGRAM WHICH IS ONE OF ONE OF
THE SEC'S FOUR MAIN
RESPONSIBILITIES AT ALL RELATE
TO LOCAL CORRECTIONS. BE A
FIFTY REQUIRED BY STATUTE TO.
PERFORM THREE ACTIVITIES THREE
PRIMARY ACTIVITIES THAT RELATED
TO THIS PROGRAM. THE FIRST IS
TO CONSIDERING REVISIONS TO THE
STANDARD MINIMUM STANDARDS FOR
THE OPERATION CONSTRUCTION OF
LOCAL DETENTION FACILITIES.
ONCE EVERY TWO YEARS TO INSPECT
EACH FACILITY- ONCE EVERY TWO
YEARS AND TO ISSUE VARIOUS
REPORTS ON THE- FINDINGS OF.
THESE INSPECTIONS. AND I ALSO
KNOW THAT STATUTE DESN'T
PROVIDE IN THE SEC WITH A
MECHANISM TO ENFORCE THE
STANDARDS. THREE EIGHTY
PROVIDES A BRIEF OVERVIEW OF
SOME MODIFICATIONS THAT THE FCC
HAS BEEN MAKING TO THE PROGRAM
OVER THE PAST YEAR IN RESPONSE
TO A DIRECTIVE FROM THE
GOVERNOR. I IN THE INTEREST OF
TIME I WON'T DETAIL THEM BUT- I
WILL NOTE THAT GENERALLY WE
THINK THEY SEEM LIKE A STEP IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION BUT-
PROBABLY DON'T GO FAR ENOUGH- I
KNOW EXPLAINED A LITTLE BIT
MORE. INTERESTING COMMENTS BUT
PRIMARILY- WHAT'S LACKING FROM
THE EXISTING PROGRAM AND THE
GOVERNOR'S. MEDICAL CARE
DIRECTED AND- DEAD
MODIFICATIONS AT THE DIRECTION.
OF THE GOVERNOR. IS ADDRESSED
ON PAGE FOR THE HAND OUT- WHICH
IS WHERE WE INCLUDE OUR
ASSESSMENT OF THE PROGRAM-
pVERY SIMPLE- WHEN WE LOOK AT
ANY PROGRAM WE ASK TWO
QUESTIONS WHAT ARE THE GOALS OF
THE PROGRAM AND USING MEETING
THOSE GOALS. AND IN THIS CASE
WE FOUND THAT THERE IS NO CLEAR
STATUTORY MISSION OR GOALS FOR
THIS PROGRAM WHICH MAKES IT
VERY. DIFFICULT TO ASSESS IF
IT'S- SOMETHING IMPORTANT STATE
FUNCTION AND TO CONTINUE TO
EXIST- IF IT'S APPROPRIATELY
STRUCTURED AND RESOURCED. I OR
IF IT'S OPERATING EFFECTIVELY-
IT ALSO GIVES FINISH DISCRETION
TO THE ADMINISTRATION AND THE
SEC AND HOW TO OPERATE THE
PROGRAM BECAUSE THEY SAID AS I
SAID EARLIER. I THANK YOU JUST
REALLY REQUIRES THE SEC TO
PERFORM REMAINING ACTIVITIES-
BUT DOES NOT TELL ME IF YOU SEE
HOW TO PERFORM THOSE ACTIVITIES
SO FOR EXAMPLE. IF YOU SEE HAVE
TO ISSUE CERTAIN REPORTS. BY
EIGHT COULD CHOOSE AND WHETHER
TO. WRITE THEM IN A MANNER THAT
IS- YOU KNOW. INTENDED FOR
FACILITY ADMINISTRATORS IF THE
GOAL IS REALLY TO BE AN ASSET
TO PROVIDE ASSISTANCE TO.
COUNTIES AND CITIES WHO OPERATE
THESE FACILITIES OR IF I COULD
WRITE IT IN A MANNER THAT'S
VERY- ACCESSIBLE TO THE LAKE
THE LAYPERSON IF THE GOAL IS
TO. PROVIDE TRANSPARENCY. TO
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC- SO
MOVING ON TO PAGE FIVE AND THE
REST OF MY HAND OUT AND
COMMENTS PERTAIN TO OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS IN LIGHT OF THE
FACT FINDING- AND JUST HAD A
VERY HIGH LEVEL WE'VE THREE
RECOMMENDATIONS THE FIRST IS TO
SET A CLEAR MISSION AND GOALS
FOR THE PROGRAM IN STATUTE THE
SECOND IS TO ALIGN BOARD
MEMBERSHIP WITH THAT MISSION
AND GOALS AND THE THIRD IS TO
REQUIRED THE SEC TO SUBMIT A
REPORT TO THE LEGISLATURE ON
HOW IT WILL ALIGN THE PROGRAM
WITH THAT MISSION GOALS. GOING
INTO THOSE EACH- IN A LITTLE
BIT MORE DETAIL FIRST WE HAVE
AN ESTABLISHMENT OF THE
COMMISSION AND GOALS NOW OF
COURSE THE LEGISLATURE COULD
ESTABLISH ANY GOALS THAT IT IT
SEEMS IT DEEMS APPROPRIATE FOR
THE PROGRAM BUT WE DO
RECOMMEND- A SPECIFIC MISSION-
WHICH IS TO PROMOTE LEGAL
HUMANE AND SAFE CONDITIONS-
WHICH WE WOULD KNOW DOES NOT
DOESN'T SEEM TO BE VERY
DIFFERENT FROM THE CURRENT
INFORMAL- MISSION OF THE
PROGRAM ALTHOUGH WE DO THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT IT BE-
CODIFIED GIVEN NOT A FUTURE
ADMINISTRATION COULD ADOPT A
DIFFERENT INFORMAL AND-
MISSION. AND THEN WE RECOMMEND
FOR SPECIFIC GOALS TO FURTHER
THAT OVER ARCHING MISSION AND
THOSE ARE ONE TO MAINTAIN
STANDARDS THAT HELP LOCAL
LEADERS DETERMINE AND MEET
MEDICAL REQUIREMENTS FOR
DETENTION FACILITY CONDITIONS
TO FACILITATE TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY THROUGH-
STANDARDS. AND INSPECTIONS OF
THESE FACILITIES. AT THREE
REFORM EQUITABLE. OF THE HE AND
SAFE CONDITION. WHEN FOR TO
PROVIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
AND STATEWIDE LEADERSHIP TO
FACILITATE SYSTEMIC IMPROVEMENT
IN LOCAL DETENTION FACILITY
CONDITIONS. AND OUR SECOND GOAL
THEY MENTIONED IS TO AFTER
ESTABLISHING- IN STATUTE.
ARCHITECT CONTAGION IF YOU IT'S
AFTER STUMBLING CONDITIONING IN
FACT YOU TO- ALIGNED BOARD
MEMBERSHIP WITH THEM. AND WE
pRECOMMENDATIONS ARE SOME
RECOMMENDATIONS UNDER THAT.
UMBRELLA- THE FIRST IS TO ADD
MEMBERS NUMBERS WITH SPECIFIC-
PROFESSIONAL EXPERTISE IN
EXTERNAL OVERSIGHT OF OR
ADVOCACY SURROUNDING DETENTION
CONDITIONS. AND THAT'S BECAUSE-
THE B. THE BOARD CURRENTLY HAS
SEVEN OF THE THIRTEEN- SLOTS
ARE DESIGNATED FOR LEADERS AND
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES FOR-
BY MANAGE FACILITIES THAT ARE
INSPECTED BY THE PROGRAM SO
THERE'S NO SHORTAGE OF
EXPERTISE ON. OPERATIONS BUT
THERE IS NO DESIGNATED SPOT
FIRST- A PERSON WITH EXPERTISE
IN OVERSIGHT AND GIVEN THIS IS
ONE OF THE SEC'S FOR- CORP
PROGRAMS WE THINK THAT THAT'S
IMPORTANT I'M IN THE SECOND
RECOMMENDATION HERE IS TO-
BALANCE THAT APPOINTMENT
AUTHORITIES BETWEEN THE
GOVERNOR AND THE LEGISLATURE
CURRENTLY THE GOVERNOR APPOINTS
TEN OUT OF THIRTEEN MEMBERS AND
THE LEGISLATURE. APPOINTS TO SO
WE THINK HAVE A BETTER BALANCE
THEIR WAY TO HELP FACILITATE.
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT. AND
MOVING ON TO THE PAGE SEVEN- WE
HAVE HERE WE- THE- WE THIRD
RECOMMENDATION WHICH IS TO
REQUIRE BE SEC CEMENT PLAN TO
THE LEGISLATURE FOR HOW IT WILL
ALIGN THE PROGRAM AT THE
PROGRAM WITH THE MISSION AND
GOALS. AND WE THINK THAT HAVING
THIS REPORT WOULD HELP THE
LEGISLATURE SS- WHETHER FOR
EXAMPLE STATUTORY CHANGES MIGHT
BE REQUIRED TO CARRY OUT THIS
ALIGNMENT OF THE PROGRAM BURKE
PERHAPS WHETHER THE SEC WE NEED
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES TO- AMONG
THE PROGRAM WITH THE MISSION
AND GOALS. AND TO GUIDE THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THE PLAN WE
RECOMMEND REQUIRING THAT THE
SEC DESCRIBED IN THE PLAN- HOW
OLD IS SHE FIVE KEY OUTCOMES.
AND THOSE ARE ONE- ENSURING
STANDARDS THAT ARE SUFFICIENTLY
SPECIFIC AND- EXPLICITLY
CONSIDER EQUITY- AND TO DO IT
IS WE THINK THAT THE PROCESS BY
WHICH STANDARDS ARE DEVELOPED
OR REVISED NEEDS TO BE- CHANGE
SOMEONE WHICH WE DETAIL IN THE
REPORT. TO THE PLAN SHOULD
INCLUDE CONSIDERATION OF- HOW
THE SEC WILL DEVELOP HIGH
QUALITY RISK BASED INSPECTION
STRATEGY TO ENSURE PRESSING
ISSUES ARE FOUND QUICKLY- THEN
THE CHANGES THAT THE GOVERNOR
HAS DIRECTED BECAUSE HE DIDN'T.
YES YOU SEE TO MAKE CONTAINS
SOME STEPS IN THAT DIRECTION
BUT OUR RECOMMENDATION WOULD-
TAKE BCC FURTHER- THREE
SPECIFIC BENCHMARKS TO ENSURE
THAT THE INSPECTIONS- PROVIDE.
EFFECTIVELY PROVIDE
TRANSPARENCY BY MAKING STATE
MAKING IT CLEAR YOU KNOW HOW
MUCH INFORMATION DIFFERENT
INSPECTORS ARE. USING IN ORDER
TO FORM THEIR CONCLUSIONS WHAT
AND HOW THEY'RE INTERPRETING
DIFFERENT- WORDS THAT MAYBE.
THEY WERE OPEN TO
INTERPRETATION TO ENSURE THAT
THEY'RE DROPPING THEM IN THE
SAME WAY- FOUR WE HAVE- WE HAVE
VARIOUS RECOMMENDATIONS.
REGARDING HOW THE SEC THE FCC
SHOULD EXPLAIN- CHANGES. ARE
PLANNED FOR CHECK CHANGES TO
ITS REPORT THING PRACTICES AND
POTENTIALLY STATUTORY REPORTING
REQUIREMENT CHANGES TO ENSURE
THAT THE REPORTS ARE ACCESSIBLE
TO LAY AUDIENCES. PROVIDE
USEFUL- INFORMATION FOR
IDENTIFYING TRENDS AND SYSTEMIC
ISSUES ETCETERA AND FINALLY-
THE PLAN SHOULD GIVE
CONSIDERATION TO PROVIDING
LONGER TERM TECH A MORE COMPLEX
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO. A
FACILITY SO THAT. THEY CAN.
ADDRESS BARRIERS TO COMPLIANCE
THAT MAYBE MORE SYSTEMIC IN
NATURE AND TAKING LONGER THAN.
THAN THE CURRENT SIXTY DAY
COMPLIANCE TO ADDRESS AS WELL
CONSIDER OF BSE CAN HIGH
PROMISING. AND FACILITATE. IN
PERSON- SO THAT'S THE END OF MY
BRIEF OVERVIEW AND I'M HAPPY TO
TAKE COMMENTS THAT THAT WERE
QUESTIONS AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME THANK YOU. I THINK YOU
WERE GOING TO MOVE ON TO THE
DIFFERENT PANELISTS AT THIS
POINT AND IF YOU COULD PLEASE
STATE YOUR NAME- WE NEED THE
LEVEL IN THE ORDER IN THE
AGENDA. MEDICARE THIS IS KATIE
HOWARD THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE BSE SCENE- WITH YOUR
PERMISSION I'D LIKE TO ASK OUR
BOARD CHAIR TO SPEAK FIRST AND
THEN I'LL FOLLOW HER COMMENTS.
THAT'S FINE. I THINK I'M ON.
YOU'RE ON AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR-
AND THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I'M PLEASED TO BE
HERE TODAY I AM LINDA PENNER I
CHAIR THE B. S. YOU SEE AND I
AM- LOOKING FORWARD TO GIVING
YOU SOME THOUGHTS AND RESPONSES
TO THE L. A. O. REPORT. FIRST
OFF- I WANT TO SAY IT'S USEFUL
TO HAVE REPORTED
RECOMMENDATIONS IN THE
OPPORTUNITY DISCUSS THAT WITH
YOU WELL WE HAVE PROVIDED YOU A
ONE PAGE SUMMARY ABOUT- THE BSE
SEES RESPONSIBILITY FOR
INSPECTING JAILS AND JUVENILE
DETENTION FACILITIES AND AS YOU
SEE THE PENAL CODE SETS FORTH
THE REQUIREMENT TO BE SEC
INSPECT ALL COUNTY FACILITIES
EVERY TWO YEARS. WE DO A GREAT
DEAL OF WORK WITH VERY LIMITED
RESOURCES WE HAVE NINE
POSITIONS DEDICATED TO
INSPECTIONS ONE OF THOSE
POSITIONS IS CURRENTLY VACANT
SO THE LAST INSPECTION CYCLE
EIGHT PEOPLE WERE RESPONSIBLE
FOR COMPLETING INSPECTIONS
REPORTS PROVIDING EXTENSIVE
ONGOING TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
FOR OVER FIVE HUNDRED FIFTY
FACILITIES. AS CAITLYN NOTED
THE GOVERNOR IS VERY CONCERNED
ABOUT CONDITIONS IN THE JAIL
AND DIRECTED US TO PROVIDE MORE
ACCOUNTABILITY AND TRANSPARENCY
IN OUR INSPECTION PROCESS. WE
BEGIN THAT PROCESS IN JANUARY
OF TWENTY TWENTY. OUR TEAM GOT
TO WORK RIGHT AWAY WE HAVE
PLACED A AND HANDSOME.
EXTENSION PROCESS- IN PLACE
WITH RESOURCES WE HAVE. DOING
THAT AND DURING THE PANDEMIC WE
HELD VIRTUAL LISTENING SESSIONS
INVITED INPUT FROM THE PUBLIC
ON THIS PROCESS OUR BOARD IN
THE FEBRUARY MEETING RECEIVED A
DETAILED REPORT ON THOSE
LISTENING SESSIONS AND I WANT
TO PROVIDE JUST A FEW OF THOSE
HIGHLIGHTS FOR YOU NOW. MANY OF
THE PARTICIPANTS IN THE
LISTENING SESSIONS WERE PEOPLE
WITH LIVED EXPERIENCE WERE MANY
FAMILY MEMBERS EXPRESSING
CONCERNS ABOUT CONDITIONS IN.
THERE WERE MANY CONCERNS
EXPRESSED ABOUT COLD IT AND
MANY RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE
BOARD THAT WE SHOULD DO AT
LEAST SOME OF OUR INSPECTIONS
AND ANNOUNCE. DISCUSSIONS ON
MANY OF THESE ITEMS ARE ON
GOING WE ARE ABSOLUTELY OPEN TO
CONDUCTING. AT SOME OF OUR
INSPECTIONS ON ANNOUNCING WE
BELIEVE IT WOULD BE HELPFUL TO
HAVE SPECIFIC STATUTORY
AUTHORITY TO DO SO JUST SO
WE'RE CLEAR ABOUT THAT.
ATTENTION THE ATTENTION ON
JAILS IN THE MEDIA AND AT OUR
MEETINGS AND HERE TODAY IS
IMPORTANT THE CONDITIONS IN
JAILS OR OF A SERIOUS CONCERN
TO ME TO THE BOARD AND TO OUR
STAFF. WE ARE OPEN TO THE
CONVERSATION ABOUT OUR
INSPECTION PROCESS AND HOW IT
CAN BE FURTHER ENHANCE THE
CONVERSATION NEEDS TO INCLUDE
THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
ADMINISTRATION. CAN WE DO MORE
OF COURSE WE CAN PLEASE KEEP IN
MIND WE ARE A STATE ENTITY THAT
WAS DESIGNED TO PROVIDE
OVERSIGHT. AND TO ESTABLISH
REGULATIONS FOR JAIL OPERATIONS
AND WE INSPECT TO THOSE
STANDARDS WE'VE CARRIED OUT
THOSE RESPONSIBILITIES VERY
WELL HOWEVER. UNLIKE CDC ARE
WITH RESPECT TO STATE PRISONS
THE STATE DOES NOT RUN THE
COUNTY FACILITIES THEY'RE
RESPONSIBLE. THE OTHER
RESPONSIBILITY OF COUNTY
GOVERNMENT AND THIS IS A VERY
IMPORTANT DISTINCTION. WE ARE
AN INSPECTION AND COMPLIANCE
ENTITY WE DO NOT HAVE
INVESTIGATIVE OR ENFORCEMENT
AUTHORITY WE DO NOT HAVE
SUBPOENA POWER WE CANNOT FILE
CRIMINAL CHARGES WE CANNOT
ISSUE FINES. WE CANNOT GO TO
COURT FOR NON COMPLIANCE ISSUES
AND SO YOU. IT IS AS IT'S NOTED
IN YOUR HAND OUT THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL. HAS PROVIDED US WITH
AN OPINION THAT WE ARE
REGULATORY. AND NOT MANDATORY.
HOW IN OF CARRYING A
RESPONSIBLE CONSISTENT WITH THE
STATUTES AND THE AUTHORITY THAT
WE HAVE. THAT WE HAVE WE ARE
ABSOLUTELY MEDIAN THE MAR I
WOULDN'T KNOW THAT IS A FORMER
PROBATION CHIEF THERE ARE
TREMENDOUS INCENTIVES FOR
COUNTIES TO COMPLY WITH THE
STANDARDS THERE ARE
CONSEQUENCES FOR FACILITIES
THAT ARE NOT ABIDING BAR
REGULATE. REGULATIONS THERE IS
A CIVIL LIABILITY QUOTIENT
THERE THERE IS LOSS OF
EMPLOYMENT AND EVEN POTENTIAL
CRIMINAL LIABILITY. THE
IMPLICATION. THAT THE BOARD
WOULD DO MORE IF IT CARED IS
YOU KNOW OFFENSIVE. THE
LEGISLATURE IS INTERESTED IN
THE BSE C. BECOMING SOMETHING
LIKE WE ARE IF THE AND THE
LEGISLATURE IS INTERESTED IN US
BECOMING SOMETHING LIKE. THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL WHICH HAS
OVERSIGHT. RESPONSIBILITIES FOR
CDC ARE AS HAS BEEN DISCUSSED
RECENTLY IT IS JUST A MUCH MORE
ROBUST AND STAFF INTENSIVE KIND
OF OPERATION. NOW I WOULD ASK
OUR EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR DIRECTOR
KATIE TO PROVIDE. ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION ABOUT WE HAVE DONE
WHAT WE'VE DONE IN THE LAST
YEAR UNDER OUR ENHANCED
INSPECTION PROCESS. THANK YOU
LINDA MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
KATIE HOWARD AND-I'M HAPPY TO
BE ABLE TO SPEAK WITH YOU
TODAY- I WOULD LIKE TO TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE BOARD'S
RESPONSE TO COATED IN THE
COUNTY DETENTION FACILITIES AND
THEN DESCRIBE IN MORE DETAIL-
THE ENHANCED INSPECTION PROCESS
WHICH WE HAVE ROLLED OUT OVER
THE LAST YEAR. I WILL USE THE
ABBREVIATION YAQUI. AFTERTHE
GOVERNOR'S DIRECTIVE LAST
JANUARY WE WORKED TO QUICKLY
PUT IN PLACE ADDITIONAL
ACCOUNTABILITY AND TRANSPARENCY
IN TORRANCE BATCHING PROCESS
THROUGH THE P. I. P. WE ARE
ALSO IN THE PROCESS OF UPDATING
REGULATIONS TO REFLECT.
NATIONAL BEST PRACTICES THAT
WORK IS IN PROGRESS RIGHT NOW.
THE GOAL OF THE I. T. IS TO
MORE ACTIVELY ENGAGED COUNTIES
WITH OUR BOARD. AND TO PROVIDE
INCREASED TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY TO ALL WHO ARE
INTERESTED. IN OUR INSPECTIONS
PROCESS. AS ONE DIMENSION WE
HAVE LISTENING SESSIONS TO
RECEIVE PUBLIC INPUT ON THAT
YANKEE. AND THE MAJORITY OF THE
COMMENTS FOCUSED ON TWO THINGS
COBIT IN THE JAILS AND JUVENILE
DETENTION FACILITIES. AND A
RECOMMENDATION THAT THE SEC BE
ABLE TO CONDUCT THE CRISIS OR
UNANNOUNCED INSPECTIONS. THE
INPUT FROM PEOPLE WITH LIVED
EXPERIENCE AND THE FAMILY
MEMBERS WHOSE LOVED ONES ARE
CURRENTLY IN COUNTY JAILS WAS
DIFFICULT TO HEAR. AND IT WAS
HEARTFELT COMING FROM THOSE
PEOPLE WHO ATTENDED OUR
LISTENING SESSIONS. WE HEARD
THE URGENT PLEAS FOR MORE HELP
FROM THE PSEC. BUT WHAT WE HOPE
FOR MAKING CLEAR TODAY IS THAT
THE BSP SEES A THORNY IS
LIMITED. AND WE'VE BEEN AS
RESPONSIVE AS POSSIBLE THROUGH
THE I. T. WE UNDERSTAND THE
CONCERNS ABOUT CODE IN THE
JAILS. THE UNCERTAINTY THAT WE
ALL HAVE FACED OVER THE LAST
YEAR HAS BEEN CHALLENGING IN
WAYS THAT NO ONE HAS FACED
BEFORE. UNFORTUNATELY SOME OF
THE SUGGESTIONS WE OFTEN HEAR
FROM STAKEHOLDERS ARE OUTSIDE
OF WHAT THE FCC HAS THE
AUTHORITY TO DO. AND ISSUES
AROUND THE JAILS RESPONSE TO
COPE WITH THE GOOD EXAMPLE.
THIS IS AN AREA WHICH THE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR PROVIDING
HEALTH CARE IN COUNTY JAIL AND
JUVENILE DETENTION FACILITIES.
IS SHARED BETWEEN THE SHERIFF
OR THE PROBATION CHIEF. AND A
MEDICAL SERVICE PROVIDER.
NONETHELESS WE- RESPONDED IN
SEVERAL AND- WAYS. WE PROVIDED
EXTENSIVE GUIDANCE ON OUR
WEBSITE TO SHARE SOME PROBATION
CHIEFS INCLUDING AT SCHOOL TO
GET ON. THAT WE DEVELOPED IN
COLLABORATION WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH. WE ALSO LAUNCHED A DATA
COLLECTION EFFORT TO TRACK WILL
BE CASES IN MID JULY. AND THAT
HAPPENED AFTER WE UNDERSTOOD
THAT THE DATA COMING TO THE
STATE THROUGH THE REGULAR
COUNTY PUBLIC HEALTH. REPORTING
PROCESS WAS NOT ABLE TO QUICKLY
IDENTIFY WHICH KOBE CASES WERE
COMING FROM JAIL FOR JUVENILE
DETENTION FACILITY. WE ALSO
PREVIEW THE LOCAL FACILITY
OPERATIONS SPECIFICALLY FOR
KOBE NINETEEN. FOCUSING ON THE
EXISTING REGULATION ABOUT THE
MANAGEMENT OF COMMUNICABLE
DISEASES INTO CUSTODY SETTING
WHICH IS REGULATION TWELVE OF
SIX POINT FIVE. NOT LIKE TO
TURN BACK TO THE ENHANCED
INSPECT PROCESS AND TELL YOU
WHAT IT INCLUDES. PLEASE KEEP
IN MIND THAT OUR INSPECTION
PROCESS IS MULTI LAYERED AND IT
INVOLVES SIX IT STANDS ATOP
BOTH SYSTEMS OUTSIDE OF ON SITE
INSPECTIONS. ARE EXPECTED SPEND
A GREAT DEAL OF TIME ENSURING
THE CORRECTIVE ACTION IS IN
PROCESS. THE PURPOSE OF OCT BUT
INSPECTIONS TO DETERMINE IF THE
FACILITY IS IN COMPLIANCE WITH
TITLE. SOME OF THE OPERATIONS
AND TITLE TWENTY FOUR
REGULATIONS ON PHYSICAL PLANT
IN THE ONE PAGER THAT WE
PROVIDED- UNDER THE E. I. P. WE
LET YOU KNOW THAT WHEN ONE OF
OUR INSPECTORS COMPLETES AN
INSPECTION THEY'LL PROVIDE AN
OF. AN INITIAL INSPECTION
REPORT IMMEDIATELY FOLLOWING
THE ONSITE VERSION OF THE
INSPECTION. THIS REPORT WILL
OUTLINE ALL OF THE OUTSTANDING
ITEMS OF NON COMPLIANCE AND IT
WILL START A CLOCKWORK ISSUES
MUST BE CORRECTED. OR
CORRECTIVE ACTION PLAN MUST BE
SUBMITTED EVERY PUBLIC BOARD
MEETING OUR DEPUTY DIRECTOR
OVER INSPECTIONS PROVIDE STATUS
TO SUPPORT ON INSPECTIONS. IF
THE COUNTY HAS SERIOUS ITEMS OF
NON COMPLIANCE THAT REMAIN
UNRESOLVED THE BOARD HAS THE
OPTION TO REQUEST THAT THE
SHERIFF OR PROBATION OFFICER
EXCUSE ME OUR CHIEF- APPEAR
BEFORE THE BOARD TO EXPLAIN THE
STATUS AND WHAT THE PLAN IS TO
CORRECT. THE ITEMS OF
NONCOMPLIANCE. SO THIS A. I. T.
INCLUDE SIGNIFICANT ADDITIONAL
PUBLIC INFORMATION THAT WILL BE
PROVIDED AT EVERY BOARD MEETING
AND ACCOUNTABILITY WITH RESPECT
TO THE REQUIREMENTS FOR
CORRECTIVE ACTION PLANS AND
FOURTEEN GAUGE BUT THE
SHERIFF'S AND PROBATION CHIEFS
IF ISSUES AREN'T ADDRESSED.
WITHIN THE STATUTORY AUTHORITY
THAT WE DO HAVE WE BELIEVE
WE'VE DEVELOPED A RESPONSIVE
AND MEANINGFUL PROGRAM FOR THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA. AS LINDA
MENTIONED WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
LEGISLATURE IN THE
ADMINISTRATION ABOUT FURTHER
IMPROVEMENTS THAT WE CAN MAKE.
IN CLOSING I WOULD NOTE THAT
THE BOARD'S STRATEGIC PLANNING
OUR PROCESS IS ALSO UNDER WAY
AND I HAVE A VERY STRONG SENSE
THAT THESE ISSUES WILL BE PART
OF THAT CONVERSATION ARE
BEGINNING AS SOON AS NEXT MONTH
FOR AN UPDATE TO OUR STRATEGIC.
PLAN THANK YOU- DIRECT. THE
MOVE A LOT OF THIS CHAIR GARCIA
AND COULD MEMBER- NAME IS YOU
BY A B. CALIFORNIA. FOR YOU
THANK ME TEST. SEE WHAT J. THE-
OF OVER THIRTY ORGANIZED. I'M
THE BEAUTY BECAUSE IT'S JUST. I
MYSELF AM FORMALLY. HAVE X.
WRAPPING UP. AND NEGLECT IN
BOTH LOCAL JUNE AND ADULT. SO I
KNOW FIRST HAND WHAT. PEOPLE
EXPERIENCE ON THE INSIDE.
THERE'S A MASSIVE NEW. BEAT
WHAT HAPPENS INSIDE FACILITIES
AND THE LIMITED ACTION AT THE
BCC TO THE TO TAKE WHEN
CONFRONTED WITH THOSE
REALITIES. REALITY TO BE A
FIFTY HAS MISSED DUE TO THE
WEAK REGULATIONS AND
INSPECTIONS. OTHER FAILURES THE
COMMUNITY HAS HAD TO PUSH HARD
TO FORCE TO BE IF YOU SEE TO
OPEN THEIR EYES. FOR EXAMPLE
SINCE LAST APRIL COMMUNITY
MEMBERS FROM RIVERSIDE HAVE
BEEN SPEAKING UP AT BCC
MEETINGS TO RUBIO WHAT IS
HAPPENING INSIDE COUNTY JAILS.
THEIR LOVED ONES ARE BEING
DENIED ACCESS TO SOAP AND
SPENDING TWENTY HOURS A DAY
LOCKED IN THEIR CELLS. LAST
FALL AND IT GETS PUSHED HEAVILY
FOR THE BE A FIFTY TO HOLD A
PUBLIC MEETING SESSION OF THE
THIRTY INSPECTIONS AT
CONDITIONS. OVER A HUNDRED
PEOPLE CAME TO THIS LESSON
SESSION AND SHARED
HEARTBREAKING STORIES ABOUT HOW
OUR LOVED ONES ARE BEING
HARMED. UNDER THE BC SHE'S
WATCHING FACILITIES THROUGHOUT
THE STATE AND PARTICULARLY IN
RIVERSIDE. JANUARY IN THE
BUSINESS TO CONDUCT AN
INSPECTION OF A RIVERSIDE JAIL.
UNFORTUNATELY THE PCC CHAIRMAN
STAFF SAID THEY WALKED OUT
FEELING BETTER THAN WHEN THEY
WENT IN. AFTER ONE SCHEDULED
VISIT THAT GAVE THE SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT PLENTY OF TIME TO
PREPARE. THE B. FIFTY BRUSH
THESE ONGOING ISSUES UNDER THE
RUG. WHEN I WAS INCARCERATED WE
ALWAYS KNEW WHEN INSPECTORS
WERE COMING ALL OF A SUDDEN CAN
SURPRISE CAME OUT AND BOTH WERE
OFFERED CHILDREN CANDY CANDY
FOR THE CLEANEST ROOMS. SOME OF
THREE MEN TAKEN INTO PRIVATE
ROOMS UNTIL THE INSPECTORS LEFT
SO WE COULD NOT TALK TO THEM.
THIS IS A WELL KNOWN TRANSIT
CORRECTIONAL FACILITIES. THE
BUSINESS IF SUPPOSED TO BE THE
EYES AND EARS OF THE
LEGISLATURE COUNTY SUPERVISORS
AND THE PUBLIC. AND THEY'RE
FAILING IN THIS ROLE
DRASTICALLY. LEAVING THE
LEGISLATURE AND OTHERS UNAWARE
OF LIFE AND DEATH CONDITIONS
AND UNABLE TO FIX THEM. THIS IS
WHY FOR THE PAST FIVE YEARS WE
HAVE RECOGNIZE THE NEED FOR
RESTRUCTURING THE BUSINESS YOU
HAVE THE FIRST STEP. AS WE NEED
EQUITABLE REPRESENTATION ON THE
BOARD FIRST LEADERSHIP THAT CAN
CARRY. OUT A NEW VISION THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRED PERCY AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS BRIAN
GOLDSTINE I'M THE DIRECTOR OF
POLICY INVOLVEMENT. WITH THE
CENTER ON JUVENILE AND CRIMINAL
JUSTICE. WE SHARE THE LEN WAS
SERIOUS CONCERNS ABOUT THE
SEC'S FACILITY OVERSIGHT. WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT
RECOMMENDATIONS TO RESTRUCTURE
THE AGENCY'S LEADERSHIP. BUT
WE'RE CONCERNED ABOUT GIVING
THE AGENCY DISCRETION TO
DEVELOP A PLAN FOR
RESPONSIBILITIES THEY'VE SHOWED
NO INTEREST IN IMPLEMENTING.
FOR YEARS WE MONITOR THE
AGENCIES FAILURES TO PROTECT
CALIFORNIANS. IN JAILS AND
JUVENILE FACILITIES. TO BE
CLEAR THE BSE FAILURE ISN'T
JUST BECAUSE THEY LACK
AUTHORITY. THIS IS THEIR CHOICE
THEY USE DISCRETION TO TAKE A
HANDS OFF APPROACH. THEY SEE
THEMSELVES AS PARTNERS OF THE
VERY AGENCIES THEY INSPECT. WE
HAVE TO SEE THE IMPACT ON HUMAN
LIVES. YET WE JUST HEARD IF YOU
TALK ABOUT WHAT THEY CAN'T DO.
LET'S SEE HOW THEIR STAFF AND
LEADERSHIP RESPONDED TO A
CRISIS A CRISIS WHICH BROUGHT
US HERE TODAY AND GET THE BE A
FIFTY STILL FAILS TO
ACKNOWLEDGE. IN JUNE TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN SB ASSISTING
FIELD INSPECTOR SAW THE KERN
COUNTY SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT.
WITH PIC WITH PLACING PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING MENTAL HEALTH
CRISIS IN BATHROOM SIZED
ISOLATION CELLS MEANT FOR BRIEF
PERIODS. STAFF HELD THEM FOR
DAYS OR WEEKS. IN EXTREME
ISOLATION WITHOUT MATTRESSES
AND SOMETIMES TOILETS. THERE
WITH A GREAT IN THE FOR BODILY
FLUIDS. STAFF FORCED THEM TO
SLEEP ON CONCRETE FLOORS. USING
THIN YOGA MATS FOR OVER A WEEK
AT A TIME. MPSC INSPECTOR SAW
THIS AND ALERTED THE SHARE THAT
THESE YOGA MATS VIOLATED STATE
STANDARDS. THE SHERIFF'S
RESPONSE BYE MORE YOGA. BE A
FIFTY THEN CHOSE TO DO NOTHING.
FEDERAL REPUBLIC THE
LEGISLATURE EVEN AGENCIES FORT.
OVER A YEAR LATER WE FINALLY
LEARNED ABOUT IT BECAUSE OF A
SCATHING INVESTIGATION
PROPUBLICA AND THE SACRAMENTO
BEE IN LATE TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN AND ENCOURAGE THE
COMMITTEE AND THE GENERAL
PUBLIC TO READ THAT ARTICLE.
NOW ANOTHER YEARS PASSED SINCE
GOVERNANCE AND TOLD THE FCC TO
STRENGTHEN INSPECTIONS AND
THINGS HAVE GOTTEN WORSE
ESPECIALLY MICROBIT WHICH IS B.
S. B. C. HAS FAILED TO ADDRESS
I'M HAPPY TO SPEAK ON. THE
ISSUE RELATES COVERT AND BCC IF
THE COMMITTEE HAS ANY QUESTIONS.
BUT CLEARLY. TO BE A FIFTIES
NEW INSPECTIONS REPORTING IS
NOT ENOUGH. THIS ONE ARE
PREVENTED WHAT HAPPENED IN KERN
COUNTY. INSPO WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE ILLEGALS
RECOMMENDATIONS. BOUGHT IN
INDEPENDENT ENTITY NOT THE NOT
THE POOREST IN COMMUNITY
CORRECTIONS MUST DEVELOP A PLAN
FOR ACTION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
TO ALL OF OUR PRESENTERS ON
THIS ISSUE ITEM. FOR EITHER OF
THE LAST TWO APELLIS THAT OVER
HERE. IN YOUR OPINION WHAT ARE
SOME RECOMMENDATIONS THAT YOU
HAVE THAT BSE COULD IMPLEMENTED
NOW THAT WOULD ADDRESS SOME OF
YOUR CONCERNS. EITHER MISTER
VIEIRA MISERABLE THING CAN
ANSWER THAT. STE SURE- THANKS
FOR THE QUESTION SO AGAIN WE
THINK IT'S THE BE A FIFTY
SHOULD IMPLEMENT THE
RECOMMENDATIONS BUT FOR BY
YELLING GO- CLEARLY- THE AGENCY
NEEDS TO HAVE- CLEAR PROGRAM A
PROGRAM. CLEAR PROGRAM MISSION
AND GOALS- THEY NEED TO I'M
TRYING TO DO A MUCH BETTER JOB
OF PUBLIC COMMUNICATION ON NON
COMPLIANCE ISSUES AGAIN THE
GOING BACK TO THE ISSUE OF KERN
COUNTY- THE FILM SPECTER
SUBURBS HAPPENING THERE. AND
THERE WAS NO COMMUNICATION
ABOUT THAT TO THE BOOK THERE
WAS NO COMMUNICATION ABOUT THAT.
PUBLIC- OR TO THE LEGISLATURE
CLEAR. NOT BE IF YOU SEE NEEDS
TO A MUCH BETTER JOB ON NON
COMPLIANCE ISSUES AND THERE
NEEDS TO BE FOCUSED INSPECTIONS
AND TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE NO THE
ISSUE OF KERN COUNTY IS ALSO
CRITICAL. NOT JUST BECAUSE OF
WHAT THE FEDERAL INSPECTORS SAW
THE KERN COUNTY HAS ONE THE
HIGHEST RATES OF SUICIDES IN
INDIA ARE COUNTY JAIL IN
CALIFORNIA. THAT'S NOT
SOMETHING TO BE A FIFTY HAS
EVER DISCUSSED I THINK THEY
NEVER BRING IT UP AT THE BOARD
MEETINGS- IT'S NOT A FOCUS AREA
AND SO CLEARLY- THE BOARD IS
NOT GETTING THE TYPING
INFORMATION THAT IT NEEDS- TO
SERVICE LEADERSHIP BODY. SO
THOSE ARE JUST A FEW OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT I WOULD
MAKE FOR HER- BCC. I MADE TO
CHIME IN A ISRAEL AGAIN YOU
WATCH THE J. I ANOTHER VERY
VERY IMPORTANT RECOMMENDED FROM
AL FROM L. A. O. IS A- TO
BALANCE THE BOARD. WHICH AT
THIS POINT IS STILL AS WE VERY
LONG DA SOUL I MANY THAT THERE
SHOULD BE A INCLUSION OF X.
OTHER EXPERTISE IS SUCH AS
MENTAL HEALTH SUBSTANCE USE AND
ABUSE- FACILITY CONDITIONS AND
ALSO I THINK OF UTMOST
IMPORTANCE TO BE INCLUSIVE OF
FOLKS WERE ACTUALLY FORMALLY
KERR STREET AND OUR SYSTEM
IMPACTED- AS OFTENTIMES YOU
KNOW THOSE OF US HAVE BEEN MOST
IF IMPACT THERE. ARE GONNA BE
CLOSER TO THE SOLUTIONS I THANK
YOU. THANK YOU ENTER BSE'S. I
GUESS FALLING OVER MR V.
BECAUSE- DO YOU BELIEVE THAT
THE MAKE UP OF YOUR EXECUTIVE
BOARD. CREATES A CONFLICT OF
INTEREST FOR DUTIES FOR. FOR
THE DEPARTMENT ARE. DOES THAT
MEAN IS. IT WOULD BE BENEFIT
FROM MORE DIVERSITY. THANKS FOR
SERVING THEIR. ALL CHAMPION
THIS IS KATE YEAH DID YOU WANT
TO GO AHEAD LINDA WELL- IT'S
CERTAINLY ARE THE MAKEUP OF THE
BOARD. HAS BEEN RAISED BY THE
LA- I THINK ALSO IMPORTANT TO
THIS BODY- WHEN WE DISCUSS THIS
MATTER IS THAT THAT- MAKE UP OF
THAT BOARD IS SET IN STATUTE-
IT IS AN ISSUE- ARE THAT CAN BE
ADDRESSED. BY THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE
LEGISLATURE- BUT IT IS NOT ONE
THAT MYSELF. OR THE STAFF AT
THE B. C. C. HAVE YES HE SHOULD
HAVE CONTROL OVER I WILL SAY
THIS WE- DO HAVE. INDIVIDUALS
ON THERE THAT ARE APPOINTED
BOTH BY THE SENATE. AND THE
GOVERNOR APPOINTEES AND OTHERS
ARE SOME OF THE MOST- ACTIVE
ARE. ACTIVISTS IN THIS OF
CALIFORNIA- WE HAVE. DAVID
STEIN. BURKE AND- NORMA COULD
BE ON WHO IS THAT I THINK JUST
RECENTLY PROMOTED TO DEPUTY
CHIEF OF- THE ANTI RECIDIVISM
RATE AND THEN- THE MOST FAMOUS
OF ALL IN ON THE PORT IS- SCOTT
BUDNICK WHO IS AN EXTREMELY
ACTIVE- MEMBER OF THE S. CBO
COMMUNITY. HE IS NOT A CBO
HIMSELF BUT HE'S CERTAINLY
WORKS ARE VERY HARD- AND SPENDS
A LOT OF TIME IN THAT.
FACILITIES ACROSS THE STATE
TALKING TO SYSTEM INVOLVED
INDIVIDUALS TRYING TO GET UP
CLOSE ON JUST WHAT'S HAPPENING
OUT THERE. HI THIS IS KATIE IF
I MAY JUST JUMP IN ON THE FIRST
PART OF YOUR QUESTION
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GARCIA HAVING TO
DO WITH WHETHER THERE MIGHT BE
ANY CONFLICT OF INTEREST WITH
RESPECT TO THE COUNTY LEVEL-
PRESENTED ITS- ARE IN THE
STATUTORY MAKEUP OF THE BOARD.
AS IT CURRENTLY EXISTS I KNOW
THAT THE DUTIES OF THE BSE
SEEKS ARM WERE VERY MUCH IN
MIND AS THAT STATUTORY MAKE UP
WAS DEFINED BACK IN. TWO
THOUSAND ELEVEN WHEN PUBLIC
SAFETY REALIGNMENT CAST- AND SO
BEAR- WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO MANAGE
THAT ISSUE EFFECTIVELY- AND
JUST TO ALSO TAKE ON WITH WHAT
LINDA SAID- IN TERMS OF THERE'S
BEEN UCH CONVERSATION OVER
MANY YARS ABOUT- INTEREST IN
THERE BEING CHANGES TO THE-
APPOINTMENT STRUCTURE AND- WE
WOULD BE. HAPPY TO BE INVOLVED
IN ANY DISCUSSIONS ABOUT WHAT
THAT MIGHT LOOK QUITE. AND THE
ONLY FINAL THING I WOULD ADD
IS- IT IS THAT. PARTNERSHIP OF
THE OF THE- NEARLY MEMBERS
ACROSS THE STATE AND THOSE ARE
LAW ENFORCEMENT PROFESSIONALS
ON THE BOARD THAT I THINK HAVE
THE BEST OUTCOMES SO I WOULD-
LOOK FORWARD TO ANY DISCUSSIONS
ABOUT YOU KNOW. HOW THAT MAY BE
BEST A SOLITARY. AND I'M SURE
GARCIA IF YOU DON'T MIND
TRIANGLE LOOKING FROM-
SUGGESTED IF I CAN JUST ADD TO
THOSE COMMENTS. YOU KNOW IT'S
INTERESTING HELLO I'M RYAN I'M
GONNA I'M GONNA INTERRUPT
BECAUSE I ASKED THE QUESTION OF
SOMEBODY ELSE EARLIER AND I
GAVE YOU A MOMENT SO- LET ME GO
BECAUSE I'M NOT DONE WITH MY
QUESTIONS FOR BSE ON THIS. SO
THIS THANK YOU. SEVEN GO BACK
TO BE SEC. US SO YOU MIGHT YOU
REFERENCE THE APPOINTEES BY THE
LEGISLATURE WHO ARE. ACTIVELY
INVOLVED. MR BUT NICK I'VE
SPOKEN TO IN THE PAST I KNOW
STILL PRETTY CRITICAL OF THIS
BOARD. I EVEN THOUGH HE'S A
STRONG VOICE THERE AND- YOU
LISTED THREE OUT OF THIRTEEN-
AND SAY YOUR OPINION THE CITY.
CREATE ENOUGH OF A BALANCE. ON
THIS BOARD. ALL I DIDN'T I DID
NOT MEAN TO SAY THAT IF THAT'S
WHAT YOU HEARD LET ME CORRECT
RIGHT AWAY AND SAY WE DO HAVE
MEMBERS. THAT ARE- OUT OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT THAT ARE ON THE
BOARD THE STRUCTURE AND THE
MAKE UP THE BOARD AS WE SAID
BEFORE IS- SET IN STATUTE AND
WE COMPORT WITH THAT. SO FROM
IN IN YOUR OPINION WHILE IT'S
THAT INFECTION THAT FOR US BUT
IN YOUR OPINION THAT THE
STATUTE THAT WE SHOULD REVISIT.
ABSOLUTELY THINK THAT'S WITHIN
YOUR PURVIEW AND IT'S ALREADY I
THINK THIS IS AN INFORMATION
FINDING HEARING. NO I A THAT'S
THAT'S NOT WHAT I SAY NOT THE
AMONG THEIR PURVIEW IN EUROPE
AND YOU SAID THAT YOU WOULD
WANT TO BE AT THE TABLE IF WE
DO REVISIT. THE ISSUE- IN YOUR
OPINION SHOULD WE BE. ACTIVELY
LOOKING TO. REVISIT THE ISSUE
AND- RESTRUCTURE THINGS. IN
ORDER TO HAVE A MORE FAIR AND
BALANCED APPROACH THAT- IS VERY
TO ALL STAKEHOLDERS IN ALL
FAIRNESS I THINK IN THE SAME
WAY THAT I WANT TO MAKE SURE
THE ADVOCATES HAVE- THE WAY TO
THE TABLE I WANT TO MAKE SURE
LAW ENFORCEMENT ALSO HAS A WAY
TO THE TABLE BOTH THE COLDER
TIME POINT IN THIS PROCESS. IS
IT. WELL IN YOUR OPINION SHOULD
WE REVISIT THE STATUE. I THINK
THIS- WHAT WE'RE DOING TODAY
LOOKING AT THE RECOMMENDATIONS
OF THE L. A. L. HAVING THE
DISCUSSION HAVING- THE ADVOCATE
COMMUNITY AT THE TABLE RIGHT
NOW GIVES YOU THE INFORMATION
YOU NEED TO DO WHAT YOU THINK
SHOULD BE DONE MY- PERSONAL
OPINION. IS YOU KNOW THAT THE
MORE. READ THE AUDIENCE SAYS
THE PARTNERSHIP BENEFITS ALL
INVOLVED THERE'S NOT ONE PERSON
ON THAT BOARD. THAT ONCE IN
HUMANE FOR TREATMENT. OF
INDIVIDUALS IN CUSTODY R. AND I
AND I STAND BY THAT- SITTING
HERE TODAY SO WHEN WE MAKE
THOSE SORTS OF ALLEGATIONS-
IT'S HARMFUL TO ALL OF THE
POSITIVE THE WORK WE HAVE DONE
AND I WOULD SIMPLY SAY WE
WELCOME ANYBODY TO THE TABLE.
TO CONTINUE THE WORK. AND MADAM
CHAIR. KATIE IF I COULD JUST
ADD A THOUGHT- LINDA MENTIONED
OF THE PUBLIC MEMBER ON OUR
BOARD AND THE GOVERNOR
APPOINTED NORMA COMMITTEE ON
LAST YEAR WHO HAS LIVED
EXPERIENCE 
THAT HER PARTICIPATION- VERY
ACTIVE PARTICIPATION IN THE
BOARD MEETING HAS BEEN A PLUS-
AND THAT POSITION IS ONLY
DESIGNATED AND STATUE THAT THE
PUBLIC. POSITION IT WAS THE
GOVERNOR'S DECISION TO CHOOSE
ENORMOUS SO I CAN CERTAINLY SEE
THE BENEFIT OF HER VOICE IN THE
ROOM. AND I WOULD ALSO ADD THAT
SHE WAS IN RIVERSIDE COUNTY
WITH US IN JANUARY. IN THE
HEART OF THE EXTREMELY HELPFUL.
I HAVE MORE QUESTIONS BUT I DO
THINK NUMBER FOR HER SERVICE
AND MAYBE WE NEED A LITTLE MORE
NERVOUS IN THE ROOM- BUT I WANT
TO MAKE SURE I GIVE TIME FROM
MY COLLEAGUES HAVE BEEN
QUESTIONS MR STONE. THANK YOU
THIS IS. SORT OF VERY CLEARLY A-
MATURING OF THE REALIGNMENT
SITUATION THAT I THINK WE FOUND
OURSELVES AND I THINK I CAN
UNDERSTAND HOW THIS CAME
TOGETHER THE WAY THAT IT DID
GIVEN THE CONCERNED ABOUT. HOW
THE STATE WAS REALIGNING THESE
RESPONSIBILITIES OUT TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND- THEY THE
PROMISE THAT THE ADMINISTRATION
THAT TIME MADE TO THOSE LOCAL
AGENCIES TO NOT INTERFERE. N.
F. AS I GO THROUGH THIS I GUESS
I DIDN'T REALIZE THAT. BSE C.
WAS REALLY SET UP MORE. AS YOU
LOOK AT IT LESS ABOUT OVERSIGHT
AND MORE ABOUT BEING AN
ADVISORY BODY PER SE TO THE
LOCAL AGENCIES AND I THINK THAT
IS WHY WE DO NEED TO TAKE A
LOOK AT. THE ROLE OF WHAT WE
EXPECT NOW B. O. C. C. TO DO
AND SET STANDARDS WERE THE
STATE'S RELIED A LOT OF
FUNCTIONS OVER THE LAST DECADE
OR MORE. INCLUDING TO THE IN
THE. THE JAILS IN RELATION
BETWEEN THE JAILS AND THE
PRISONS BUT WE'VE DONE IT IN
OTHER HUMAN SERVICES WE'VE DONE
AND A LOT OF DIFFERENT AREAS
AND THE ONE THING THAT I'M
CONSTANTLY CONCERNEDABOUT AND
WE'RE SEEING THIS I THINK IN
THIS CASE IS IF THE STATE'S NOT
VERY CLEAR ABOUT SETTING OUT
STANDARDS AND HAVE WAYS TO
ENFORCE THOSE STANDARDS IT IS
TRUE THAT IT'S UP TO LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS TO IMPLEMENT AND
THEY'RE GOING TO IMPLEMENT IN
THEIR WAY. BUT IF WE'RE NOT
SENDING SOME BASELINE STANDARDS
AND BEING VERY CLEAR ABOUT THE
FORTIES THEN WE'RE GOING TO END
UP WITH A SITUATION LIKE THIS
WHERE IMPLEMENTATION IS VERY
DIFFERENT COUNTY BY COUNTY. AND
I DON'T THINK THAT'S THE
CALIFORNIA WE WANT TO SEE. SO
IT IS. CLEAR THAT IT'S TIME
THAT WE REALLY TOOK A LOOK AT.
THE MAKE UP. OPSEC END IF END.
REALLY BOLSTER THEIR ABILITY TO
DO THE OVERSIGHT THAT WE
EXPECT. AND THAT MEANS AND THAT
IS SOMETHING THE LEGISLATURE IS
PRIMARILY CHARGED WITH IS
OVERSIGHT OF THE ACTIVITIES HE
ADMINISTRATIVE ACTIVITIES BOTH
THE ADMINISTRATION AND THE
JUDICIARY. AND WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT AN ORGANIZATION LIKE
BE IT C. C. HAS THE APPROPRIATE
TOOLS HAS THE APPROPRIATE
MEMBERSHIP HAS THE APPROPRIATE
AUTHORITIES. MISSION STATEMENTS
AND ALSO ARE THE OUTLIERS WERE.
REPORT HERE IS I THINK VERY
INSTRUCTIVE AT PROVIDING US
WITH A BIT OF A PATH FORWARD.
AND COMING UP WITH STRONGER
STATEMENTS AND THAT IS OUR
RESPONSIBILITY MATCH THAT IS
THE JOB OF THE LEGISLATURE.
ANTS TO ENSURE THAT THE FCC IS
SET UP. TO PROVIDE THAT
OVERSIGHT BUT ALSO ABOUT THE
LEGISLATURE TO DO ITS
OVERSIGHT. OF THOSE FUNCTIONS
WITHIN THE ADMINISTRATION SO I
THE IT LOOKS TO ME LIKE THE SEC
EVEN THOUGH THERE ARE SOME VERY
SERIOUS COMPLAINTS AND SOME
CONCERNS. BUT HAS BEEN TRYING
TO MEASURE UP TO HOW THE DAY
WERE STRUCTURED IN THE
AUTHORITIES THAT THEY WERE
GIVEN. BUT WHEN I LOOK AT THIS
IT WAS REALLY A FAILURE OF. THE
INITIAL ENABLING STATUTES TO
CREATE AN APPROPRIATE STRUCTURE.
AND ALLOW FOR THE OVERSIGHT
INPUT AND TRANSPARENCY AND
REALLY THAT'S ON US AND THAT IS
ACTUALLY ONE REASON THAT IT'S
INTERESTING AND BUT I THINK
VERY WISE OF THE SPEAKER TO PUT
THE CHAIR OF THE PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE ON THIS SUB COMMITTEE
BECAUSE THIS IS AN INTERSECTION
OF POLICY. AND BUDGET THAT IS
REALLY ULTIMATELY VERY
IMPORTANT BECAUSE AS WE DO
OVERSIGHT WHICH WE DO THROUGH
THE BUDGET PROCESS. WE'RE ALSO.
GIVES US THE OPPORTUNITY TO
LOOK AT THIS STRUCTURES THAT WE
HAVE PUT IN PLACE OR HAVE BEEN
PUT IN PLACE OVER THE YEARS
THAT LEGISLATION PUT IN PLACE.
TO ACCOMPLISH VARIOUS THINGS
THAT I AM JUST NOT SURE BCC IS
ACCOMPLISHING WHAT WE NEED THEM
TO BE ACCOMPLISHING AT THIS
POINT IN TIME. AND TAKE A LOOK
AT THE OVERSIGHT THE STATE
PROVIDES TO THESE LOCAL
AGENCIES. TO DO THE BEST JOB
POSSIBLE AND- ALL OF THE TALK
HERE BOTH IN THE L. A. REPORT
IN FROM MEMBERS OF BCC RIGHT
NOW ABOUT BEST PRACTICES. AND
PROVIDING SORT OF THAT
OVERSIGHT AND- N. REQUIRING
LOCAL AGENCIES TO MEET MINIMUM
STANDARDS WE CAN HELP SET THOSE
MINIMUM STANDARDS AND THINK
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT WE
SHOULD DO THEN I THINK WE WOULD
HAVE MUCH BETTER OUTCOMES FOR
PEOPLE WHO ARE CURSED RATED AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL WHICH WAS THE
POINT WOULD BE A CC WAS THE
POINT OF WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
LOOK AT AS WE TRY TO CLEAN UP
THE STATE LEVEL. SYSTEMS THAT
IT THAT ECKHART'S THREE PEOPLE
IT IS ALSO OUR RESPONSIBILITY
TO REQUIRE CERTAIN MINIMUM.
CAPACITY CAPABILITY AT
EXPECTATIONS EVEN AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL SO THAT'S REALLY WHAT I
THINK OUR TASK IS HERE IT'S
PRETTY CLEAR I DON'T KNOW IT'S
GONNA TAKE SOME HARD WORK
BETWEEN THE ADMINISTRATION THE
LEGISLATURE TO MAKE AND THE AND
THE ADVOCATES IN THIS CASE. TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE SETTING
UP THE CORRECT SYSTEM BUT IT
JUST SEEMS TO ME IN THIS
CONVERSATION THAT THERE'S NOT
AT THIS POINT A DISAGREEMENT
THAT THIS NEEDS TO BE DONE AND
THAT THERE IS A PATH AHEAD OF
US OF COURSE THE DETAILS AS
ALWAYS WILL NOT NECESSARILY BE
THE EASIEST BUT THAT'S THAT'S
THE ROLE THAT WE HAVE HERE. TO
APPRECIATE MADAM CHAIR THE
DISCUSSION HERE AND BRING IN
THIS ITEM FORWARD. AND IT'S
JUST VERY CLEAR THAT WE NEED TO
TAKE A LOOK AT HOW WE HAVE
IMPLEMENTED OF THIS REALIGNMENT
AND LOOK FOR PLACES LIKE THIS
WHERE THERE ARE CLEAR NEEDS FOR
STATE STANDARDS AND IMPLEMENT
THOSE STANDARDS. THANK YOU.
MISTER JONES SAWYER- CHAIR
PENNER AND EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
HOWARD OF WE'VE MET ON SEVERAL
OCCASIONS I CAME IN. IN TWENTY
TWELVE WITH SEVERAL MEMBERS ON
ON THIS COMMITTEE AND I TALKED
ABOUT THE INEFFICIENCIES OF
PSEC- AND AT THAT TIME WE
TALKED ABOUT. HOW THINGS WERE
CHANGING AND THAT B. S. C. C.
NEEDED TO BE PART OF THAT. IT
WASN'T UNTIL THIS COMMITTEE
THIS MINUTE ED IN SOME WAYS YOU
MAY EVEN NEED TO APOLOGIZE TO
PSEC BECAUSE IT LOOKS LIKE.
YOU'RE STILL OPERATING. N. IN A
WAY THAT YOU WERE START. AND
WE'RE AT A TURNING POINT WITH
RESPECT TO CRIMINAL JUSTICE-
FOLKS LIKE MYSELF AND OTHERS
WHO HAVE BEEN CALLING FOR AN
INCREASED FOCUS ON
REHABILITATION. ARE NO LONGER
ALONE IN PUSHING FOR REFORM.
AND MAYBE THE DATA SET UP AS
YOU POINTED OUT TO US. THAT WE
CREATED LEGISLATIVELY NEED TO
BE CHANGED I MEAN I SIT HERE
AND I SEE THE BOARD. OF STATE
AND COMMUNITY CORRECTIONS.
COMMITTEE TO ME MEANS LOCAL
JAILS AND SHERIFFS AND- BY YOUR
OWN ADMISSION YOU SAY YOU HAVE
NO CONTROL OVER THEM YOU CAN'T
TELL THEM WHAT TO DO SO WHERE
IS THE COMMUNITY PART OF IT-
ESPECIALLY SINCE IS MORE
IMPORTANT THAN EVER THAT WE GET
THINGS RIGHT WITH RESPECT TO
LOCAL. DETENTION FACILITIES. IN
PROP FORTY SEVEN PROP FIFTY
SEVEN A REALIGNMENT OF DJJ WE
WILL BE HOUSING MORE AND MORE
INDIVIDUALS IN JAILS AND
DETENTION FACILITY IS
ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL SB SEC
PROVIDE EFFECTIVE OVERSIGHT OF
THESE FACILITIES. AS WE E. A
STATE CONTINUE TO PUSH FOR
CILIC FACILITIES AND PROGRAMS
TO REFLECT BEST PRACTICES FOR
ENCOURAGING REHABILITATION AND
SUCCESSFUL REINTEGRATION INTO
SOCIETY. IT IS MORE- BUT- IT IS
CRITICAL THAT PSEC PROVIDE
EFFECTIVE OVERSIGHT IF SO HE'S
QUITE FRANKLY AND WE AS A STATE
SHOULD PUSH TO CONTINUE PUSH
FOR CIVILIANS AND PROGRAMS
REFLECT BEST PRACTICES FOR
ENCOURAGING REHABILITATION AND
SUCCESSFUL REINTEGRATION IT HAS
BEEN SAID THAT TODAY'S
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUAL BE
TOMORROW'S NEIGHBOR WE SHOULD
CONTINUE TO PUSH FOR NEIGHBORS
TO RECEIVE THE BEST EDUCATIONAL
VOCATIONAL AND OTHER SUPPORT
THAT. THEY NEED TO THRIVE I
WOULD PARTICIPATE IN STATE
COURT IN DISCUSSIONS ABOUT
USING OUR FUNDING SOURCES TO
INCENTIVIZE REHABILITATION LAW
ENFORCEMENT CANNOT CONTINUE
WITH BUSINESS AS USUAL THEY
MUST EMBRACE A PERSON FOCUSED
REHABILITATION APPROACH RATHER
THAN CONTINUING TO LOCK HIM UP
AND THROW AWAY THE KEY TACTICS
OF THE PAST. SO BE SEC. HAS BY
THEIR OWN ADMISSION SAID THAT
THEY ARE HAMSTRUNG. BY THE
LEGISLATURE AND WHAT WE PUT IN
PLACE. AND SO WE AS A
LEGISLATURE NEED TO LOOK AT ALL
VIABLE MEANS TO NOT ONLY CHANGE
THE COMPOSITION OF THE B. SEC
WHICH LOOKS LIKE IT SERVES TO
PROTECT THE STATUS QUO. BUT WE
NEED TO MAKE IT NâNG BALANCED.
BUT ACTUALLY LOOK AT WHERE
WE'RE MOVING AT THE STATE WHERE
WHERE WHERE THE PUBLIC WANTS US
TO MOVE- THAT INCLUDES EVEN
LOOKING AT SHARES AND SHARES
TRAINING. THAT WE PUT YOUNG
CADETS IN THE SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT IN. IN JAILS TO
WHERE THEY BECOME ACCUSTOMED TO
KIND OF A VIOLENT. WAY OF
INTERACTING WITH THEIR
CONSTITUENTS. AVACEN OFFICE AND
LAW ENFORCEMENT I SHOULD BE
INCENTIVIZED TO ADULT
REHABILITATION FOCUSED. OR
POSSIBLY LOSE THE MONEY THAT WE
GIVE THEM AND WE NEED TO
RETRAIN LAW ENFORCEMENT AS WE
MOVE DJJ KIDS THE COUNTY
DETENTION. ALL OF THIS CAN'T
HAPPEN. IF WE CONTINUE TO DO
THE SAME THING OVER AND OVER
AGAIN AND EXPECTING DIFFERENT
RESULT AND SO I WILL WORK WITH
MY COLLEAGUES TO ON BOTH SIDES
OF THE AISLE. BOTH THE
ADVOCATES. AND PEOPLE IN LAW
ENFORCEMENT THAT WE START FROM
SCRATCH. WITH THIS ORGANIZATION
CALLED THE B. S. C. C. AND WE
HAVE A HONEST DISCUSSION WITH
OURSELVES WHAT DO WE WANT THIS
ORGANIZATION TO DO BECAUSE
OBVIOUSLY IT'S NOT DOING WHAT-
WE WANT THEM TO DO RIGHT NOW IN
TWENTY TWENTY IT MAY MADE SENSE
BACK IN NINETEEN NINETY
NINETEEN EIGHTY NINETEEN
SEVENTY BUT- IT IS NOT WORKING.
AS WE MOVE FORWARD AND SO WE
REALLY DO HAVE TO HAVE THAT
HONEST DISCUSSION I ALSO THINK
WE NEED TO MOVE FAIRLY QUICKLY-
TO DEVELOP THOSE TO DEVELOP
THAT NEW STRUCTURE- IF WE DON'T
WE'RE SENATE DJJ KIDS DOWN TO
DATE COULD RETURN ABOUT MONIES-
THERE'S HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS INVOLVED IN THIS AND SO
IF WE DON'T GET THIS RIGHT- WE
WILL CORRECT PROBLEM IN THE
LOCAL AREAS. THAT- WE WILL
DIDN'T REGRET SO- MADAM CHAIR
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD. BUT MOST IMPORTANT- AS
CHAIR PUBLIC SAFETY. I THINK WE
HAVE A DAUNTING TASK ON HOW WE
MOVE. THE BOTTOM ARRAY OF.
DAUNTED ARE NOT I THINK WE MADE
A COMMITMENT TO. I CALIFORNIANS
TO WORK ON THE TASK AT HAND AND
SO WITH THAT I'M GONNA PASS IT
OVER TO MR LACKEY. YES THANK
YOU. I JUST HAVE A QUESTION FOR
ANYBODY FROM THE SEC. MY
QUESTION WOULD BE WHAT THE
BOARD IS NOT GIVEN EXPRESSED AT
THIRTY TO ENFORCE REGULATIONS
ON LOCAL DETENTION FACILITIES.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER OVERSIGHT
ENTITIES. OR LEGAL AVENUES FOR
ENFORCEMENT. LINDA PENNER AGAIN
OUT THE CHAIR OF THE BOARD AND
YOU KNOW ITS- BASICALLY AS I
SAID WE HAVE- SOME PEOPLE OUT
OF COMPLIANCE AND THEN- WE KNOW
THAT THERE HAS BEEN SEVERAL-
REMEDIES. WHEN THAT IN FACT
HAPPENS IT IN TERMS OF ANOTHER-
THERE IS NO- I. G. THERE IS NO-
STATEWIDE ENTITY THAT INSPECTS
OTHER THAN US THERE ARE HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS LOCALLY- THAT GO IN
AND DO THEIR PORTION OF AN
INSPECTION. AND I THINK- WHEN
THOSE THINGS ARE FOUND OUT OF
COMPLIANCE WE HAVE SEEN A
NUMBER OF- CIVIL SUITS
ASSOCIATED WITH THAT IT IS A
COMPLICATED EQUATION IN THAT-
THERE ARE. ELECTED OFFICIALS
RUNNING FACILITIES THERE ARE
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS THAT HAVE
OVERSIGHT OF THE BUDGETS FOR
THOSE FACILITIES THERE ARE
APPOINTED CHIEF PROBATION
OFFICERS ACROSS THE STATE AND-
THE OPERATION OF THESE.
ENTITIES IS FIFTY EIGHT
DIFFERENT ARE. SHAPES SIZES
AND- IT IS A DAUNTING TASK TO
SAY THAT WE CAN LOOK AT ALL OF
THEM THINK THAT THEY ARE ON
EQUAL FOOTING THE RESOURCING
AND WHAT GOES ON OUT THERE
MAKES IT DIFFICULT WITH THAT
SAID OUR INSPECTIONS ARE
CERTAINLY GOING IN AND TAKING A
HARD LOOK AT WHAT WE ACTUALLY
SEE INSIDE OF THE FACILITY BUT
THEY ARE BACKED UP BY LOOKING
AT THE POLICIES AND PROCEDURES
LOOKING AT- OF BACK UP
INFORMATION- TO ENSURE THEIR-
DOCUMENTATION SAYING THAT THEY
ARE. DOING WHAT THEY'RE SAY
THEY ARE DOING IN A FACILITY-
CERTAINLY YOU'RE- THE
LEGISLATURE WANTS US TO HAVE
GREATER AUTHORITY- AS I SAID
EARLIER WE ARE WILLING TO DO
WHATEVER JOB WE ARE TASKED WITH
DOING. OKAY- LET ME JUST SAY
THIS FIRST OF ALL- THE
POPULATION THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT. PROVIDING INSTRUCTION A
CARE FOR IS A COMPLEX.
COPULATION IMPRESSED TO
CHARACTERIZE IT ONE WAY OR THE
OTHER I THINK IS PROBLEMATIC.
AND FIRST OF ALL WHEN AND THE
WHOLE SPIRIT OF REALIGNMENT.
BEING COMMENDABLE THERE ARE
SOME INHERENT PROBLEMS FROM THE
GET GO THERE WERE NEVER
ADMITTED TO. FIRST OF ALL GELS
WERE NEVER DESIGNED FOR LONG
TERM INCARCERATION. HUGE
PROBLEM HUGE PROBLEM AND THERE
ARE JUST SOME. SOME INHERENT
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT I THINK. RBS
CC'S PROBLEMS THERE ARE
PROBLEMS AS LEGISLATORS AS
OVERSEERS AS POLICY CREATORS
WHERE THE WHERE THE ONES OF.
PUT HIM IN THIS THE-
UNSUCCESSFUL SITUATION KNOWN
FORSMAN AUTHORITY AND OVERSIGHT.
RESPONSIBILITY AS CONFLICT. I
MEAN AND THEN WE TRY TO BLAME-
THE OVERSIGHT. GROUP OF PEOPLE
FOR THE PROBLEM. I THINK THAT-
THIS IS CLEARLY SOMETHING WE
NEED TO. THE EVALUATE AND I
THINK. WE JUST HAVE TO BE
CAREFUL I THINK BALLOTS ALWAYS
NEEDS TO BE THE GOAL. AND I
WILL I HOPE THAT- BALANCE IS
NOT ONLY A CONCERN WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT THIS PARTICULAR
ASPECT IN PUBLIC POLICY THAT
DOESN'T SEEM TO BE A PROBLEM
ELSEWHERE BUT THIS IS CLEARLY A
POPULATION THAT WE ALL BENEFIT
FROM IF WITH THAT ARRIVE IN OUR
GOAL OF REHABILITATION HOWEVER.
WE ALSO HAVE TO BE- IN A
SITUATION THAT THOSE WHO ARE
CARRIED OUT WITH THE
OVERSTEPPING ARE ALSO PROTECTED
AND SO THAT THOSE ARE THE
BALANCES THAT NEED TO BE
CONSIDERED AND I LOOK FORWARD
TO BE A PART OF THE TEAM TO
ADDRESS THESE. CHALLENGES IN A
MEANINGFUL WAY BUT THERE'S SOME
POLICY ADJUSTMENTS THAT NEED TO
BE MADE IMMEDIATELY. AND I AND
I LOOK FOR TO BE A PART OF THAT.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS ON
THE OVERSIGHT ISSUE MR LIKE AND
SO I DO HAVE A OF FOLLOWING UP
WITH THAT THEN- A QUESTION FOR
THE SEC. IF YOU WERE PROVIDED
WITH THE OVERSIGHT OR
ENFORCEMENT METHODS. ARE THERE.
ARE THERE SPECIFIC METHODS THAT
YOU THINK- WOULD BE THE MOST
EFFECTIVE TO ENSURE COMPLIANCE.
I'D LIKE TO START ON THAT THIS
IS KATIE HOWARD EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR- HANTS INSPECTION
PROCESS AND I AM HOPEFUL THAT
WITHIN THE EXISTING RESOURCES
AS WENEED MORE REGULARLY
REPORT TO THE BOARD I WILL
CONCEDE THERE HAD NOT PRIOR TO
THE ENHANCED INSPECTION PROCESS
BEEN. REGULAR UPDATES GIVEN TO
OUR PORTS THROUGHOUT THE YEAR
WE GENERALLY MEET SIX TIMES A
YEAR ABOUT THE ISSUES THAT HAVE
BEEN- IDENTIFIED IN OUR
INSPECTIONS SO I THINK THAT'S
GOING TO PROVIDE A WHOLE LOT
MORE INFORMATION TRANSPARENCY
AND ACCOUNTABILITY WE'RE ALSO
POSTING THOSE INITIAL
INSPECTION REPORTS ONLINE. AS
SOON AS THEY ARE COMPLETED- SO
AGAIN THAT'S MORE OF THE WITHIN
EXISTING RESOURCES YES WE CAN
DO MORE TO HAVE MORE
TRANSPARENCY AND INFORMATION
AVAILABLE- WITH MORE RESOURCES
WE CERTAINLY COULD DO MORE. ARE
THERE. THANK YOU FOR THANK YOU
FOR THAT AND THANK YOU FOR THE
ADDITIONAL- HAS FRIENDS IN A IN
A MEETING WITH US AND HAS
INSPECTION PROCESS ARE THERE
SPECIFIC METHODS OF ENFORCEMENT
IN YOUR EXPERIENCE THAT YOU
THINK WOULD BE THE MOST
EFFECTIVE IF WE ARE BEGINNING A
DISCUSSION OF HOW WE DO THIS
BETTER. ON HOW WE MOVE FORWARD
WITH THEIR GOALS AND HOW WE
LEARN FROM FROM THE MOMENT WHEN
ARE THERE SPECIFIC- ENFORCEMENT
MEANT THAT THAT YOU THINK.
WOULD BE EFFECTIVE IN ENSURING
COMPLIANCE. AS WEAK AS WE
CONSIDER THE WORK AHEAD OF
REFORM. I I WANT TO GET THE
MOST DIRECT ANSWER THAT I CAN
BUT UNFORTUNATELY I THINK THIS
OPENS UP REALLY HUGE POLICY
TANGLE IF YOU WELL WHEN IT
COMES TO THE STATE OF THE
LIMITS ON THE STATE'S AUTHORITY
TO DIRECT. HOW THE COUNTIES DO
THINGS SO- I WOULD JUST NOTE
THAT IS A BIG CHALLENGE IN THIS
WHOLE DISCUSSION AREA- AND YOU
KNOW I THINK. AGAIN THOSE ARE
THE THOSE ISSUES COME UP FAST
ACROSS SO MANY DIFFERENT POLICY
ISSUE AREAS THE STATE AND
LOCAL- DIFFERENCES AND- THAT'S
WHY I WAS SO INTERESTED TO HEAR
THE RECENT DISCUSSIONS. OUT OF
THE- ALLY G. IN THE VARIOUS
BUDGET HEARINGS BECAUSE THAT'S
AN ENTITY THAT DOES HAVE THE
ABILITY TO HAVE OVERSIGHT AND
ENFORCEMENT WITHIN THE STATE
STRUCTURE THIS IS DIFFERENT
WHERE THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
WITH OUR- COMPLIANCE
RESPONSIBILITIES. WITH RESPECT
TO FIFTY EIGHT DIFFERENT COUNTY
GOVERNMENTS WHO ARE THE ACTUAL
ENTITIES RUNNING THESE
FACILITIES. JUST WAIT A MINUTE
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
OPENET- I THINK THE MEMBERS
HAVE HAD GREAT COMMENTS AND
NOTING THE COMPLEXITY OF THIS
ISSUE AND- I HAVE TO. REITERATE
WHAT- EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR HOWARD
JUST MENTIONED ONE OF THE
ISSUES WITH. YES YOU SEE IN
THEIR OVERSIGHT ROLE IS BACK IN
BEING PRESCRIPTIVE FROM A STATE
AGENCY TO THE COUNTIES AS FAR
AS MANDATE IT MUST AND MUST NOT
DO. IT OPENS UP POTENTIAL
ISSUES WITH STATE REIMBURSABLE
MANDATES ARE PROP THIRTY
TRIGGERS AND I THINK. THAT'S
ONE OF THE DIFFICULT ISSUES. OR
DOES IT YOU CAN NAVIGATE HOW.
DIRECT COUNTY AND PROVIDE THEM
WITH. AND TECHNICAL. WITHOUT
ISSUING ANY KIND OF. IRAQ
MANDATE THAT WOULD BE
REIMBURSABLE BY THE STATE
SAVINGS I THINK IT'S A VERY
COMPLICATED ISSUE BUT THE
RESTORATION IS HAPPY TO HAVE
THE CONVERSATION IN SUPPORT OF
MOTOR ROBUST OVERSIGHT OF THAT
COUNTY JAILS. SO IT'S THE I
THINK IT'S COMPLICATED SO WE
LOOK FORWARD TO ENGAGING IN
THIS DISCUSSION TO DO THE
PROCESS BETTER- AND WE CAN LOOK
AT THE POSSIBILITY OF THE STATE
GIVING MORE MONIES ARE GIVING
MONEY TO THE COUNTY IN THIS
PROCESS BUT IT NEEDS TO COME
WITH THE KHAN ABILITY IN
TRANSPARENCY IN ENSURING THERE
WERE GETTING THEIR MONEY'S
WORTH AND SO BOTH OF THE POLICY
PROCESS PART PROCESSING
COMMITTEES THANK- MISTER JONES
SAWYER IS A PUBLIC SAFETY OR
THROUGH THIS BUDGET PROCESS
THIS DISCUSSION MUST CONTINUE.
SO WE CAN'T ACTUALLY MEET OUR
GOAL FOR MOVING FORWARD AND
HONOR OUR COMMITMENTS. AT THAT
TOO WE LOOK FORWARD TO THAT
ENGAGEMENT. I ARE THERE ANY
MORE QUESTIONS ON THIS TOPIC
LET ME MINDFUL OF TIME IS. A
THAT IS. THE REAL QUICK TO THE
ONLY- HAVE ANY. EXAMPLES OF
OTHER OVERSIGHT AND TO SEE
ENTITIES THEY WOULD ENVISION
THAT THE B. B. SEC SHOULD LOOK
LIKE OR OPERATE. AND YOU KNOW
WHAT THE L. L. AND THERE ISN'T
ONE- THIS. INDIVIDUAL ENTITY
THAT WE IDENTIFIED THAT- FILLED
ALL THAT. PURSUES THE SAME
GOALS THAT WE RECOMMENDED AND-
HAS A PROGRAM IN LINE A LINE
WITH THOSE GOALS IN THE WAY THE
SPECIFIC WAYS THAT BE
RECOMMENDED- BUT THERE ARE A
VARIETY OF. ENTITIES OUT THERE
THAT HAVE BITS AND PIECES OF
WHAT WE- HAVE RECOMMENDED FOR
THE DIRECTION THAT THE STATE GO
WITH RESPECT TO THE SEC
STANDARDS AND INSPECTION
PROGRAM FOR EXAMPLE- TEXAS USES
A- A VARIETY OF DIFFERENT
PIECES OF. DATA ON AND- JAIL
OUTCOMES AND PROC BOTH SO FOR
EXAMPLE DEATHS OR- AT YOURSELF-
CERTAIN RESPONSES- ORDER
CRITICAL EVENTS GOING ON IN THE
JAILS WORK- IN REPORTING
STANDARDS VIOLATIONS THEY THEY
GATHER A VARIETY OF DIFFERENT
SOURCES OF INFORMATION- AND USE
THAT TO INFORM THEIR INSPECTION
STRATEGY. TO HOPEFULLY I AM
IDENTIFYING TARGET THE
FACILITIES THAT ARE MORE LIKELY
TO HAPPEN MOST SERIOUS ISSUES
AND THE GOVERNOR HAS- DIRECTED
THE SEC TO TAKE A STEP IN THIS
DIRECTION BUT WE AS WE OUTLINED
IN THE- REPORT. WE THINK THAT
THAT THAT AGENCY CAN GO
FURTHER- AND TEXAS IS ONE
MODEL- AND THEN AS FAR AS
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE WE HAD A
NUMBER OF RECOMMENDATIONS ON
THAT AND TENNESSEE ACTUALLY IS-
EXAMPLE WE POINT TO A REPORT
BECAUSE. THEY HAVE A- I
CONSULTANT THAT WORKS. AND THAT
IS IN. FROM THE STATE STANDARDS
AGENCY BY- WORKS CLOSELY WITH
THAT AGENCY TO. PROVIDE AND NOT
FROM AN ENFORCEMENT
PERSPECTIVE- THE FOR MEN
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
PERSPECTIVE- LONGER TERM
SUPPORT TO FACILITIES THAT ARE
OUT OF COMPLIANCE THAT ARE
DEALING WITH THE- ISSUES THAT
MR LACKEY POINTED OUT FOR
EXAMPLE. WHERE IT'S NOT
NECESSARILY SOMETHING THAT THE
FACILITY ITSELF CAN CHANGE-
DIRECTLY AND CERTAINLY NOT
WITHIN A SIXTY DAY COMPLIANCE
BECAUSE IT MAY INVOLVE OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS SUCH AS- THE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY OR THE BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS AND MAKING A
REALLY COMPLEX SYSTEMIC ISSUE-
AND SO THAT. TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE CONSULTANTS IS
AVAILABLE TO HELP AND DOES IT.
SELL AND COMMUNITIES COME
TOGETHER AND ADDRESS THE ISSUE.
THAT'S SOMETHING WE RECOMMEND
THIS YOU COULD SEE CONSIDER-
AND THEN FINALLY ANOTHER
EXAMPLE THAT WE POINT TO IN THE
REPORT IS THAT IT. OFFICE OF
THE INSPECTOR GENERAL WHICH
OVERSEES STATE PRISONS IN
CALIFORNIA AND I WAS NOTED IT
IS- IT FILLS IN A LARGE DEGREE
A DIFFERENT TYPE OF OVERSIGHT
THERE'S VERY VERY IS DIFFERENT
OVERSIGHT- FUNCTIONS THAT ARE
DISCUSSED IN THE LITERATURE ON
CORRECTIONAL OVERSIGHT AND
HAPPY TO. GET MORE IN TUNE IF-
IF THAT BE HELPFUL BUT AT A
HIGH LEVEL- REGULATION IS JUST
ONE TYPE OF OVERSIGHT FUNCTION-
THAT THAT IS PROBABLY THE
CLOSEST THING TO WHAT THE FCC
DOES BUT THEN THERE'S
MONITORING- WHICH IS MORE KIND
OF LOOKING AT HOLISTICALLY HOW
ARE THE PEOPLEIN THIS
FACILITY- BEING TREATED- AND
IT'S MORE IN. A KIND OF. LONGER
TERM LOOKING AT X. AND THERE'S
INVESTING. WITH TO THE A
SPECIFIC IN THAT HAPPENED. WHAT
WENT WRONG HERE- THOSE ARE ALL
DIFFERENT FUNCTIONS AND- I. G.
DOES SOME OF THOSE FUNCTIONS-
SO THAT'S WHAT PART OF THE
REASON THEY HAVE A BIGGER-
BUDGET BUT AND- IT'S MARIN
STAFFING INTENSIVE AS WAS
NOTED- BUT WHAT THINK ONE THING
WE POINT TO IN THE REPORT THAT.
WE GOT THAT THEY DO
PARTICULARLY WELL IS THERE
REPORTING STYLE- IT'S REALLY
IT'S A LOT WELL ALIGNED WITH.
THE SEVERITY OF THE VIOLATION
IT'S KINDA WELL ALIGNED WITH-
HOW SORT OF THE INTENSITY OF
THE REPORT THAT THEY PRODUCE
AND THE SPEED WITH WHICH THEY
PUT OUT A REPORT- TO SET TO
SOME DEGREE SIR KIND OF. THEIR
KIND OF RAISED ALARM IN A IN A
WAY THAT FEELS A MORE
APPROPRIATE RELATIVE TO. THE
ISSUE AT HAND- IT'S ALSO A VERY
ACCESSIBLE- LANGUAGE FOR THE
LAY AUDIENCE AND THEIR WEBSITE
HAS- MAKES IT. IS VERY
INTERACTIVE AND EASY TO LOOK
AT. TRENDS IF YOU LISTEN AND
THEY ALSO SORT OF. TRY TO
SURFACE SYSTEMIC ISSUE BASED ON
THAT- THEY'RE NOT JUST SPEAKING
TO THE FACILITY ADMINISTRATORS
BUT- RAISING ISSUES THAT MAY
REQUIRE THE LEGISLATURE TO ACT
ON AND GIVEN THAT THEY HAVE
EYES ON THE FACILITY BOOTS ON
THE GROUND. I THINK THE SEC IS
IN A POSITION TO DO- SOME OF
THAT TYPE OF WORK THAT DATE
THEY ARE IN A GOOD POSITION TO
IDENTIFIED SYSTEMIC. ISSUES
WE'RE NOT WE'RE NOT SAYING THAT
THEY SHOULD REPLICATE THESE
PACKAGING. BUT UT WE THINK
THERE'S SOME USEFUL LESSONS. TO
BE DRAWN. AND THE PS. DO YOU
THAT YOUR- IS A PER. SO TO MEET
THE SUGGESTIONS BOTH THE
COMMITTEE ON. THAT THE L. A. O.
PROPOSED. WE ARE NOT MADAM. WE
ARE IF THERE'S AN EXPANSION OF
DUTIES I MEAN OBVIOUSLY THE
NUMBERS WE PROVIDED YOU EARLIER
WITH- C. MIKE AND AN OBVIOUS
NEED IF WE EXPANDED DUTIES.
THANK YOU. I WANT TO THANK ALL
THE MEMBERS FURTHER QUESTIONS
ON OUR PANELIST- IF WE ARE I
THINK WE'RE GOOD I WE ARE NOW
ACCEPTING PUBLIC COMMENT BOTH
IN THE HEARING ROOM AND ON THE
PHONE. THE PHONE NUMBER TO BE
CONNECTED TO- THE PHONE NUMBER
TO BE CONNECTED IS ON THE
COMMITTEE WEBSITE THE AND
GENDA. AND SHOULD ALSO BE ON
THE SCREEN IF YOU'RE STREAMING
THE HEARING. JUST IN CASE THE
NUMBER IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN.
SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE
SEVEN. AGAIN THAT'S EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN. OUR ACCESS CODE FOR
THAT IS ONE THIRTY ONE. FIVE
FOUR THREE SEVEN ONE AT THREE
ONE FIVE FOUR THREE SEVEN IF
YOU ENCOUNTER ANY PROBLEMS
PLEASE CANNOT CONTACT THE
ASSEMBLY BUDGET COMMITTEE AT.
916-319-2099 AND A STAFF MEMBER
WILL ASSIST YOU WILL THING
CHRIS THE PUBLIC TO PROVIDE
READ IMPALA PUBLIC TESTIMONY AS
WELL. THEY COULD BE SUBMITTED
AT BUDGET SUB FIVE AT ASM DOT
CA DOT GOV AND THAT EMAIL IS
ALSO LISTED ON THE AGENDA. DO
WE HAVE ANY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC IN THE ROOM WHO WISH TO
SPEAK. SEEN NONE I WILL ASK THE
OPERATOR TO PLACE UP IN THE
PHONE LINE FOR PUBLIC COMMENT.
EACH PERSON HAS UP TO ONE
MINUTE FOR PUBLIC COMMENT.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT PRESS THE ONE
THEN ZERO AGAIN ONE THEN ZERO
IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT. ALL
STAR AT LINE SIXTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
AND WE GALLAGHER HERE I AM WITH
ANTI RECIDIVISM COALITION.
CLICK ON THE BSE REPORTED A
COMMUNITY CORRECTIONS. WELL
ORGANIZATION DOES HAVE BOARD
MEMBERS NUMBER COMPOUND AND A
FORMER- FOUNDER. BUT MAKE UP ON
THE BOARD WE RECOMMEND AND AN
AGREE WHAT THE ALLULOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS TO BALANCE THE
BOARD MEMBERSHIP TO FACILITATE
OVERSIGHT TO ENSURE THAT THE
BE. THE FISHING EXPERTISE AND
GUIDANCE IN OVERSEEING LOCAL
DETENTION. WE RECOMMEND THAT
THE LEGISLATURE CONSIDER
EXPANDING THE BOARD WITH
MULTIPLE BOARD MEMBERS BUT
DIRECT JUVENILE AND CRIMINAL
JUSTICE EXPERIENCE AND
PROFESSIONAL ADVOCATE. FOR AN
OVERSIGHT OF DETENTION
CONDITIONS THEY ARE BUYING THAT
DID IT THANK YOU FOR THE BOYS
TO RESPECT ABOUT PERSPECTIVE
AND EQUITABLE DECISION MAKING
BODY. OF THE STREET AND WE
RECOMMEND THAT THE BOARD BE AT
LEAST COMPOSED OF 50% NON LAW
ENFORCEMENT COMMUNITY
REPRESENTED. LAST WEEK WE ARE
THE LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER
CHANGING THE BEER YOU BUY EXTRA
REQUIREMENTS INCLUDE ANY MEMBER
ON THE BOARD MADE CLEAR AT THE
BACK J. THANK YOU FOR TAKING
THE TIME. TO CONSIDER A ARGUED
RECOMMENDATION. THANKS CALLER.
THANK LINE CAN PLEASED AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON DOMINIQUE
NONCHALANTLY DEFENSE FUND
CALIFORNIA SPEAKING ON ISSUE
FIVE. REGARDLESS OF ANY
LIMITATIONS WITHIN THE BST IS
ORIGINAL STRUCTURE TO BE IF
THEY HAD FAILED TO FULLY
EXERCISE THE POWERS THEY DO
HAVE TO PROTECT ON COURT STREET
AS WELL AS ONE. SPECIFICALLY
THEIR POWER TO TECHNICALITY
STANDARDS. ALL OF THE H. AT THE
HAVE BEEN SO LOW BUT IT WAS
ONLY. YEARS AGO THAT THE
STANDARDS WHICH- TO REQUIRE
FILL THESE FROM YOU WITH THEIR
OWN SET OF NON SUPPORT
UNDERWEAR. FOR THIS CHANGE YOU.
INCLUDING GOLD. BUNCHED AS YOU
SHARE THEIR UNDERWEAR WITH
OTHERS AND MANY WERE FORCED TO
WEAR FLIMSY SCRATCHY DISPOSABLE
UNDERWEAR. AND A CHANGE WITH
ONLY THE RESULT THE COMMUNITY
MEMBERS LOCAL I THINK AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT REPRESENTATIVES TO
OPPOSE THE PROVISION. EARLIER
ADVOCATES HAVE TO FIGHT JUST TO
HAVE STANDARDS REQUIRED STAIN
FREE UNDERWEAR. I HOPE FUTURE
CONVERSATIONS WITH CLOSELY NOT
ONLY AT WHAT POWERS THE BEER HE
DOES NOT HAVE THAT WOULD BE
NORMAL. THEY HAVE HAD FOR YEARS
AND FAILED TO USE TO UPHOLD THE
DIGNITY OF. INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU KNOW CALLER. THANKS A LOT
SEVEN PLEASE CALL. HELLO MY
NAME IS AB ONE EDWARD AND I
WORK WITH DOZENS OF FAMILIES
WITH LOVED ONES IN RIVERSIDE
COUNTY JAILS. THE RIVERSIDE
COUNTY SHERIFF TOLD PRESS IN
APRIL THAT QUOTE IF YOU DON'T
WANT TO CATCH THE VIRUS DON'T
COMMIT A CRIME. CURRENTLY THERE
IS NO MEANINGFUL OVERSIGHT FOR
SHERIFF LIKE HIM SHE CALPERS
REGARDS THE LIVES OF PEOPLE IN
HIS CUSTODY HAS RESULTED IN
NEARLY A THOUSAND COULD BE KIDS
AND I THINK TO THAT.
INDEPENDENT THOUSANDS OF
RIVERSIDE COUNTY JAIL SUFFERED
FROM TWENTY THREE HOUR A DAY
LOCKDOWNS AND INTO MAY NOT HAVE
ACCESS TO COPE NOT TACK
CLEANING THE BY THAT PHONE
CALLS. ONE MAN A FIFTY TWO YEAR
OLD VETERAN SUFFERED A BRAIN
ANEURYSM IN CUSTODY LAST YEAR
AFTER BEING DENIED ACCESS TO
THE MEDICATIONS AND BREEDING
MACHINE. ANOTHER YOUNG MAN IN
CUSTODY WITH CONNECTICUT MENTAL
HEALTH NEEDS WAS GIVEN A PUZZLE
BOOK WHEN YOU REQUESTED ACCESS.
TO MEDICATION BENEFIT BUT- MANY
HAVE REPORTED THE THEY HAVE
ONLY RECEIVED ONE. THROUGHOUT
THE ENTIRE BLOCK YEAR'S
ECONOMIC. REBEKAH FAMILY
MEMBERS. YET MEET ON THE LIST
SESSION RECORDING HUMANE
CONDITIONS THE CASE. THE
FREQUENT FOR THE LAST SEVERAL
MONTHS. URGING THEM TO. OF THE-
INSPECTION. BY THE BMC THE
FINAL INSPECTED THE FACT JAIL.
MONTH INSISTED CAN GET. WITH
THEIR ENHANCE INFECTION PROCESS.
THANKS TEAM FEELING. ABOUT THE
STATE OF THE FACILITY. NAME
ONLY ONE ISSUE OF NON
COMPLIANCE. DOCUMENTATION IT IS
EVIDENT THAT THE MAJORITY OF
THE DAY IF SAME FOUR MEMBER
ANNA SECTION GAME. DO NOT HAVE
THE INTERESTS OF THOSE MOST
IMPACTED BY DROUGHT CONDITIONS
IN OUR STATE. THE SO CALLED
OVERSIGHT PROVIDED BY THE FTC
IS OFFENSIVE TO REVERT BACK
FAMILIES AND I LOOK LIKE IN
CUSTODY COULD CONTINUE TO
SUFFER FROM INHUMANE JACKING
DITION WEEKS. AFTER THE
INSPECTION THANK YOU. THANKS
CALLER PLEASE. MAXO LINE MAY
PLEASED AHEAD. CORRECT MY NAME
IN OUR WITH THE SAN ON JUNE
CRIME JUSTICE THANK YOU ISSUES.
THE BBC IS TO FULFILL ITS BASS
RESPONSE. IN THE LAST BIENNIAL
INSPECTION CYCLE THE FTC WAITED
TO INSPECT ABOUT 40% OF
FACILITIES UNTIL THE FINAL FEW
MONTHS OF THE PERIOD THEY THEN
HALTED INSPECTION DUE TO COOK
IN NINETEEN LEAVING CONDITIONS
THE NEEDS DISABILITIES ON
THIRTEEN ENTIRELY. FOR YEARS
PSEC HAS DEVELOPED SUBPAR
FACILITY REGULATIONS IN PROCESS
IS DOMINATED BY THOSE THAT RUN
THESE FACILITIES. AND FAILED TO
HOLD COUNTIES ACCOUNTABLE. BBC
CLAIMS COULD NOT HAVE DONE MORE
WITH IT. YET WE ARE HERE IN
LARGE PART BECAUSE THE NEWS
ARTICLE BY PROPUBLICA IN FACT
HE HAS SUCCESSFULLY PRESSED THE
STATE TO ADDRESS THE FTC
SHORTCOMINGS. IN ITSELF SHOWS
THE POWER OF STEPPING UP AND
COMMUNICATING WHAT HARM IS
BEING DONE TO HUMANS. PSEC HAS
KEPT IN THE DARK AS HARMFUL
CONDITIONS HAVE UNFOLDED UNDER
THEIR WATCH. THE AGENCY LACKED
POLITICAL WILL AND VISION FOR
THE FUTURE. I URGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO CAST AN
INDEPENDENT ENTITY NOT BE SEC
WITH DEVELOPING A PLAN THAT
EXPORTS SIGNIFICANT
IMPROVEMENTS TO STATE
OVERSIGHT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER. MAX STILL APPLYING
TWENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS DANIEL
SANCHEZ ON BEHALF OF THE CHIEF
PROBATION OFFICERS IN SUPPORT
OF REGARDING SB SIX SEVENTY
EIGHT SB SIX SEVENTY EIGHT
PROGRAM REPRESENTS REALLY ONE
OF THE MOST SUCCESSFUL CRIMINAL
JUSTICE REFORMS IN CALIFORNIA
BY SUPPORTING THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF EVIDENCE
BASED PRACTICES TO PROVIDE
MEANINGFUL ALTERNATIVES TO
INCARCERATION. I THINK
IMPORTANTLY THERE HAS BEEN OVER
A DECADE OF DATA TO SUPPORT
THIS PROGRAM AND THE SUBSEQUENT
REDUCED PRISON POPULATIONS AND
THINKING TO THE STATE PRESIDENT
ACT MEANT I'D REALLY DUE IN
LARGE PART TO THIS COMMITTEE
AND THE BODIES CONTINUED
SUPPORT WE CERTAINLY WANT TO
WORK CLOSELY WITH THE
LEGISLATURE AND ADMINISTRATION
TO MAKE SURE WE CONTINUE THIS
PROGRAM THANKS. VERY READ BOOKS
WAY. THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
MEXICO MEGHAN I YOU WISH TO
COMMENT PRESS THE ONE THEN ZERO
NOW AGAIN ONE THEN ZERO TO
COMMENT. AT THIS TIME THERE'S
NO ONE ELSE IN THE QUEUE. WITH
THAT I'D LIKE TO THANK ALL THE
PANELISTS MEMBERS AND PUBLIC
WHO PARTICIPATED IN TODAY'S
HEARING IN RETURN THANK YOU. HE
THE MAN CARE THANK YOU FOR A
ROTH. VERY MUCH.